all right and we are
live the last word with lord cognito
and ibontis friday morning fresh at the
campfire once again
what's going on e oh you know we got um
we got some awesome charity work going
on this week which we'll talk about in a
second
we got some teases of stuff coming up in
the fall before we get to talking about
anything that we got in here right now
we've got a gentleman joining us from
across the pond this morning joining us
with his afternoon break
because uh he's ahead of us in the time
travel world he jumped through the
corridors of time a little bit as we
said
before class so let's get this man
introduced so we can uh
get this thing rolling yeah man let's do
it welcome
to the last word episode number 108
and it's another glorious friday we're
back in front of the campfire for some
more lunar shooter discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guests so we're going to get right into
it
i want to introduce a lord whose
meteoric rise as a destiny content
creator has truly been
a sight to behold now is this lord the
epitome of informative and concise
information
but his commentaries guides and reviews
of some of the very best
in the lunar shooter community
introducing
the creating host of the jar venus
youtube channel and contributor to the
iconic planet destiny movement
lord ivantas's fellow last rights member
and recently the 6 million channel
viewed man
live from london uk and kind enough to
make his debut
at the campfire of the last word
my man lord y'all venus how you doing
sir
how am i supposed to live up to an
introduction like that that's insane
bro you're the campfire man we gotta
introduce you right we gotta show you
some laughs man
when you put things out like that that's
uh you forget all the little things man
when you
when you lay it out like that that's in
an insane
set of achievements right there yeah
that's crazy you're gonna walk around a
little taller a little broader in the
shoulders a little strut today
you know a little straighten that step
how you doing man what's been going on
man otherwise how you been otherwise
yeah been good man it's been a hectic
start to a season as we spoke about
before the show
um 15 videos in 10 days or something
crazy and i'd start calming that down a
little bit
uh for you guys but it's uh yeah it's
been crazy and uh
everything like that it's been a it's
been kicking off and massive
achievements like you say six million
was something that
i didn't even think i'd hit when i
started it so uh to have to smash
through it and uh
you've been crushing it man absolutely
anybody who's noticed you at all
that absolutely on fire so no it's it's
well deserved and a lot of hard work put
in and paying off so it's
you were in the right place doing the
right things no doubt no doubt man
so yeah when you when you got the news
man i mean i i saw you you subtweeted
kind of
like when you do like it might happen
and then it's like boom you know
that too won't happen right so that that
that was really cool to see
man so i actually had a couple of
questions for you too um in reference to
obviously
why are we here this this game of ours
that we seem to continue to play
consistently despite the masses
sometimes wondering why we still play
this game but for you
personally i always wanted to jar of
like where where did this love for
destiny
really start like how did that whole
thing develop for you
um i've been a massive uh bungie fan uh
for a long time um
me and my other half my wife we we
played halo together a lot
uh we played them through back to back
uh
getting all the skulls things like that
so we spent a lot of time doing that
and just the the way bungie games feel
to play
is unmatched so when they were like
moving on to like
a new ip from halo into destiny and
seeing some of the concept i was just
like yep
sign me up um you know alpha and beta
and you know
creating this social world and creating
and building friendships like
with you guys and stuff that would not
even exist if it wasn't for even a game
like destiny you know destiny's made
friendships
and more for a lot of people around the
world so
um we would never expected this when it
first died but yeah just uh to see where
it's come
since it was uh started its development
nearly uh probably nearly what's it now
2012 wasn't
when they first started talking about
destiny
yeah it's a decade in the making even if
a couple of those years were behind the
scenes
but yeah it's like i mean you have the
iconic company of bungie and then they
go completely out on the limb and make
something like this and people's first
raids like tie people to together and
everything it's
no it's been kind of an amazing
experience so it's kind of nice to see
another person remind us of like
how it hits you yeah yeah you go you go
in with
you know just that transition from one
insane ip
to a next and then it becomes something
else that completely transforms your
your life and your friendship circles
and things like that so it's uh
it's crazy to be honest but um yeah and
to see how they can put a raid in a
first person shooter always intrigued me
and if anyone was going to pull it off
it was going to be bungee right so
absolutely absolutely we talked about
that offline how like you know
i always talk about other lunar shooters
and that hook right that thing that kind
of gets you
to come back and it's just something
about you know bungie as far as like i
said the dungeons and the raids and
you know pvp that in-game content kind
of stuff but um
so as like as you were going on with it
like um you know
what was the what what were those
specifically the hooks it was just a
bungee name what like
specific like class any what with the
combination of things
that really got you to stay invested
um i've had a couple of clans along the
way um i think one of my first
experiences was
bumping into people in the cosmodrome
and yes um
and then joining their fire team and
then joining them again a few days later
creating a small
network of friends create our own little
clan join a part of a bigger clan
i was part of that for over two years um
separated ways with them created our own
clan
uh off the back of that and that grew uh
and we sort of
we met deidre egx over here in the uk
and uh
you know massive uk uh clan i'm personal
friends
with a lot of them and i still chat to
them on the day today
but managing a clan and then trying to
create content
is a full both of them are full-time
jobs um
and you just yeah you can't do both it's
impossible so
you know just to find a clan that was
you know doing relatively well and
to hand it off wasn't an easy decision
but it was the right one for them and it
was
uh you know i feel it's obviously a
right one for for me too
i still um to talk and chat and
play when i can with them they're cool
but yeah it's the friends and the social
networks it creates is
is uh unquestioned really uh and it
wouldn't be possible without
what destiny has done really to be
honest bridge brother you said it you
said it well man it's those connections
right don't
the people you meet people you come
across with interact with all that good
stuff
just so so cool man so then you go on
with it you stick with it you change up
the clans you do it doing this stuff so
the content creation part like how did
that start like what made you say you
know what
i'm gonna do like a youtube channel i'm
gonna get out there
you know and you want to produce content
about the game
yeah i guess everyone tries
or you know some people if they want to
do that we'll give it a go i tried that
back in
2016 was when i first created my youtube
channel and i did maybe half a dozen
videos
uh also not really knowing how
or what i wanted to sort of produce or
just putting them out there and they got
a few views and like i said before the
show most of them were probably me
you know
today i was looking for the three people
like i can look at my list of subs i
know who's on there where you at
so you have you have those initial
challenges as a content career
especially on youtube is that
discoverability
um and you know that sort of i guess
switched me off a little bit because you
know i wasn't really seeing the
engagement there which is normal when
you're brand new but when you're brand
new to content creation you might not
you know your expectations are much
higher
than you know your early achievements at
least anyway
um and ev you know twitch was relatively
newish i guess
that's you know how old i am i guess but
um
just about a millennial thing just about
um
this uh yeah try streaming for a bit i
did that um
for six or seven months or so
and then um pd was changing hands they
obviously they've gone quiet
into uh for a period of time and then i
got i've taken over
uh and moon picked up the reigns and has
been rebuilding it uh so
from the ground up from the inside uh
you know to produce
the content that we all know and love
planet destiny was huge for me as a
as a fan of the game and you know going
back
um and you know a lot of people that
were part pd then are still uh you know
producing incredible stuff and uh
you know to be able to be a part of that
and there wasn't even an official
positions available in terms of being a
streamer for pd and i
just saw moon sort of just taken over as
sort of general manager
and i was just like i'll just send her a
dm you know just a bit of opportunistic
approach hey you gotta shoot
yeah you know if you don't try you know
i said to myself what's worse
they're gonna say no you know i'm i'm in
the same position i am
now before i send anything you know and
my content was you know
i'd like to try and keep it positive and
keep positive spin but you know if
there's stuff to call out or happily
discuss those things you know
and also it creates a bit of a platform
for them in a time zone that
they might not be able to support
normally so it's like okay cool thinking
outside the box there
yeah yeah let's see look how he assessed
his value you see how did that eat that
was smooth that was like a dc
yeah yeah outside the box with these
things
[Laughter]
so i remember sending that dm and then
going on my night shift like we spoke
about before the show
coming home and moon dm'd me in the
morning and it's like you know do you
want to
you know do you want to call so i was
like yeah cool it was like 7 a.m uk time
was
like i'm on this voice call and stuff we
have a you know conversation for half
hour 45 minutes or so and uh
you know next thing i know i've got like
a a thursday slot
week in week out on for planet destiny
which just seemed insane
uh at the time because it was just like
they were part of something that i've
been watching
as a player of the game for for years so
to suddenly find myself on
on their roster and when they when they
tweeted out and my twitter was blowing
up i was like what have i got myself
into that my twitter's exploding
um you know it's that's sort of
set me on that path i guess um
so yeah that's where i got into content
creation initially and then
i was obviously on twitch at the time so
now there's the transition to where i am
now right so
and this goes back to my my clan mates
because obviously i was a lot of my game
time was with them i was streaming it
was grading
with them um a lot of the time if you're
not live on twitch
uh you're not growing it's very hard to
grow on twitch if you're not live right
so
i'm working on a four on four off night
shift of uh you know
wife family and everything it's very
hard to keep a consistent schedule
okay um you know i'm live every monday i
can't be if i've got
you know kids to get to bed or i'm at
work and stuff like that so
absolutely having that consistent
schedule was almost an impossibility
as a streamer um so i had a conversation
with her one of my close friends liam in
the clan
and i was like look give youtube a try
again dude you know you weren't bad at
it you just need to find
you you know and what do you go on
youtube for
uh you know and you know if you're going
on there there's a
there's a gap there try and plug that
gap um
so um youtube's the second biggest
search engine
outside google which is owned by google
so as a new content creator you know
anything that gets yourself into search
traffic is a good way to start
you know what people searching for
what's going to make my video appear
because they're not going to search
necessarily for
like a you know you know ride along for
unless you're established content career
and stuff like that
um but if you're putting yourself in
search results then you give yourself
a bit of a different approach on things
so that's where i sort of angled myself
that's why i've got mostly guides hints
and tips and
you know things of value people's time
as a dad myself
i don't get a lot of time as a content
creator i get even less time
to play the game so anything that means
that i can
jump into in-game content and maximize
my play time is a benefit
to me as a gamer and as a dad and i like
to think that
also admits to other players in the
community as well and
with the success we're seeing it's quite
clear there's a there's a need for that
type of content
oh yeah oh yeah absolutely absolutely
yeah i wanted to ask you one more before
i pass to eat was um one thing about
chicano is really cool like i said it's
very
concise very informative especially the
way you do your guides and everything
you know i love what you said in
reference to you know
you your schedule knowing that you don't
have a lot of time like i
i love that a lot of your stuff is just
like you go right in you know what i
mean like there's
it's that a lot of filler you're getting
into the business so that part about it
is
cool and as far as like you know doing
like walk-throughs the commentary and
stuff like that you know you did you
make a conscious decision to say hey i
just want to just stick to this type of
content as opposed to i don't know
law or other different things is it was
it was it kind of like just helping
people out with the
you know guides reviews things of that
nature yeah pretty much i think when i
was
with my clan and doing a lot of raids
and streaming i was the one doing the
explaining a lot of the time
so when you can clearly explain
how to do something and why you need to
do something not just stand there and
shoot stuff
you know what i mean i'm not one of
those guys that's just like i don't want
those guys that would just
tell you to stand there and shoot
something you need to be involved and
understand it so next time you come here
you can you know be a bit more free in
your play
so if you can i felt i was quite good at
explaining stuff i mean we finished
raids so we must have been i must have
been doing something right uh
yeah so i took that and i was like okay
let's try and
uh see if i can adapt that into other
things um
other things players would be looking
for and that's that's where we go with
like the power level
videos i guess the farms and all that
we've seen this season have been
popping off massively because you know
people want to get into the end game
content we spoke about it a lot before
the show
you know the dungeon is a perfect
example of that and it's going away it's
the biggest
fomo they've added to the game you know
i mean
you know people want to get on that and
the power level is the only thing
stopping them doing that
and that's why the afk fund became such
a a thing because people want to get in
there they want to
it's the only end game content that has
farmable armor
yeah that can take you up to the end of
year four so
it you know anything that allows players
to get that a bit easier and access that
easier
is gonna do well and that's you know
that's what's happened more recently i
guess awesome man what you got for me
because i i
go all day no no i mean you're hitting a
lot of the questions so
it's uh just kind of sitting here
letting him talk but uh
yeah it's just like it's interesting to
go through some of the things that you
do and you're like you'll run the guide
real quick and i was going to ask you
just as like a content creator for you
is like
the appreciation of like when you did
youtube and you did twitch and then you
kind of came back to youtube and stuff
so
do you have like a routine are you like
a script guy are you off the cuff
are you like i mean how many how much is
in the editing trashcan and stuff like
that for you just like
any little nuggets of fun that you've
had during like making videos that you
can uh
share with uh some of the up-and-coming
ones out there to
you know let them know what it's like um
i do a lot of i'm a very
visual person i try to visualize a lot
what i try and create in my mind like if
i was sitting here watching this video
is this engaging to me and it's also
understanding that not everyone is
actually watching your video with their
eyes so if they had that
on is it still hitting the notes you
know so whether it's
an audio piece or a visual piece you
need to be hitting those two things and
if you hit both of those
then you're going to see better
engagement on your videos uh
generally anyway so yeah i'm a very
visual person so i will map it out on
the timeline exactly how
i would want that information to be
presented to me like why
you want to do something what it does
and the best way to do it seems like
this sort of like
the you know the what where and why
questions are pretty common
but if you can stretch them out in that
sort of way where you're
putting yourselves in the player's shoes
then you know that helps you
resonate with them as well because we
are we are players you know we are
all one of the same i'm just making the
video for you to make it easier so
there's a couple of the things that i
sort of put in my mindset i guess when
i'm trying to create a video
um some stuff is scripted together
some of it is off the cuff normally if
it's like in the timeline and i've
stretched it out visually which is
normally what i do in the day when i've
got kids running around the house i
can't do commentary and stuff
which is normal my time tell you what
dude if i wasn't in the uk i'd be
screwed because the time zone saves me
so much when the daily resets at 6 pm
and my kids are having dinner and i have
bath and bed almost straight away
afterwards and stuff
you know this is saving grace for me
getting a video out at 8pm uk time which
is really good for you guys over in the
states all right so
absolutely yeah so it's a saving grace
being in the uk really although
it has its advantages i'm sure there's
some people that will say that but
destiny won when the reset for me was
like three or four in the morning which
you would have been like
lunch so i mean that was like 10 10 or
11 a.m i think
um which was good was good when i didn't
have any responsibilities and i could
just wake up and play games one
[Laughter]
when day have responsibilities and stuff
outside of content creation it's uh
you know and if it wasn't for my other
half my wife i wouldn't be able to do
this
right now so um she she takes a lot of
the
heavy lifting in the house and will
support me for doing that
and without that i wouldn't have the
freedom to do it so it's not a one-man
army
there's a team that makes it happen
awesome
that's awesome yeah shout out to the the
other halves of the world out there who
support and deal with them oh yeah so
the grown men playing video games
and screaming into microphones and
editing staring at computer screens for
hours on end when we're home
they'll be like hey i want to hang out
with you and be like i'm stuck in here
for like a good six hours i'll see you
later yeah
yeah i know that's right like 24 hours
crazy like yeah i mean season launches
expansions i mean may as well just shut
down like social life and stuff for a
week sometimes it's just it's a
different type of thing
yeah she knows what that means and she
gets notifications when i post a video
she's like
can we have dinner now can we hang out
for a bit
so give me give me a half an hour let me
go through some comments and then we'll
spend some time that is awesome
it takes a special person i give you
guys that takes a special person to deal
with that especially we know our crazy
destiny gets
especially come you know new expansion
time
that prep period right before all the
hype all the craziness i know you guys
want to get the content out
you know as quickly as possible as
concise as possible but one thing that
i want to commend both you and e that
you guys do is you guys speak
very well to the new destiny player or
play a player
who's just not as familiar you don't
assume or talk down like they you know
they you're supposed to know everything
and you guys break things down in a very
cool way so i always appreciate content
like that
because like you said like i was always
that guy myself like you know okay
you know looking and trying to trying to
get something as far as you know
efficiency what's the best efficient way
to do something
or things of that nation i think i
watched one of your um your guys on 600
um auto rifles which i really appreciate
it
how you broken down you had you had my
galley art in there you had someone in
there
you know and then you kind of you know
you did it in a cool way where you
showed the advantages you show where you
know you get stuff from
and i i just love i love the minutia the
way you do things and also again in a
very
in a way that's easy and accessible so
that anybody can get in yeah and i'm
sure he will probably agree
that's a conscious thing and i see a lot
of comments occasionally i see a lot of
comments occasionally they'll be the old
comments like
you speak like you know we're dumb and
we haven't played the games like
okay but you you probably are like me
and you played this game for nearly a
decade
and if you look at the uptick on like
new light videos since april when
everything went into lockdown like
there's probably a you know upwards of
100 percent more new light players than
there were at the beginning of the year
more people are at home playing destiny
so you can't really make that assumption
and that's a conscious thing for me when
i'm putting my content out is that
not in layman's terms but it needs to
try and be
accessible to more players yeah that's
the key because again
last point i'll say on this and this
kind of translates into i think there's
gaming
as a whole like you know sometimes us as
the hardcore
forget that we're really the minority
there's more people that don't know
about the stuff
than the people that actually know about
it so it's always cool
that you're thinking that way you know
i'm saying because it gives people to
have not
that's really cool man you're saying he
i catch you you're about sister
that's like i'm just waiting my turn
over here well my bad
no but it's like same thing it's like i
made and it's like and
i was like jarv and i are it's like
somewhat similar on this it's like
you take the person it's like you take
any guide that you do and i've gone
through whether it be
stupid you know solo nightfall videos or
even just the one i did for like
leveling i was like
i was going through and like leveling a
little bit and i had my brother in my
discord channel and he doesn't get to
play as much so he just doesn't get to
like watch he doesn't follow on twitter
he doesn't always read like you know on
everything on the same day so it's like
if i'm going through stuff like plucking
his brain sometimes just as more of
someone who's like hey let me let's just
lay everything down
break all the pieces down what's the
order and some people are saying hey
what's the best way
my leveling guide is probably way too
long of a video but there's a lot of
stuff if you picture and go for somebody
who's like literally just logging in at
750
to go all the way to try and get to 1016
just to try and break it down explain
why and what's going on
and stuff like that so it's there's so
many different
pieces to this game and people log in
and they're like new light is
overwhelming overwhelming so much stuff
to do and especially when somebody
started a new stream account just to
experience it
and i just feel sorry for new life
players
and i'm glad that bungie are really
looking at that whole experience and how
that feels for a new player
going into beyond light um with more the
cosmic drone seemingly being available
it seems for them
based on what luke was saying yep and
because you go to the tower and just
like speak to everyone
and there's so many npcs man it's so
almost
so true it's so true yeah it's there so
it's
it's overwhelming for sure
[Music]
what else we got going on e in the world
well um first thing we definitely gotta
touch on is gcx their streams are going
on right now
and guardian con will probably episode
number 108 where we tell you guys where
we met
yeah yeah no but it was like that's
where we met we've been like
obviously not going this year but next
year is going to be the craziest gcx
ever because everybody's got so
everybody's so pin up to go out this
year next year hopefully is going to be
crazy good um
but yeah they're doing their charity
stream right now and yesterday was
bungee's block and
they absolutely crushed it
so for those of you guys that got to
watch it um last year when they did
their
uh gcx stream they i think barely
squeaked into 400k or 380 or
and that was huge like they were
absolutely doing awesome
yesterday they had i think i'd have to
look in my discord to see
i think they had 150 000 raised in like
15 minutes
which was absolutely insane they ended
up with over 800
000 for the entire four-hour block that
they had
they blew away their stretch goal of
like 500k they made up a couple other
goals as they were going through
all the community managers are getting
tattoos now
it was a lot of fun so i wanted to see
if you guys had a chance to catch it see
highlights or just hear anything about
that because
i got to catch a decent amount of it and
then i had to break for the last bit but
it was
cool to watch i've got quite any of it
i caught the whole thing yeah i was uh i
mean i was editing stuff i had it i was
getting stuff on the timeline typical
typical me but i had it on for sure um
and i'll tell you what some of the
talent in that studio it was just a
great opportunity
to see that and i think we spoke a bit
before about some of the you know bungie
have this social face
and we you know we know a lot of people
very well but we only really scratch the
service when it comes to the talent
that's in the studio so
to have the opportunity to see some of
the artists actually come on
and you know present are in different
ways
live was just incredible just to see
some of the talent they had and
some of the law readings the feels dude
gave me goosebumps man
when more love the lore
[Laughter]
oh my god yo he did it that doesn't cut
your job
he did it so hilariously accurate
that i know biff hey i had to laugh like
you have to laugh anybody saw this
it's complete bife inflections the whole
bit
deej is amazing i just had to i just
shot him out man shout out to deez i was
there you should be
doing impressions stuff but continue joe
we talk about the artists you were
talking about everything
you were seeing and how like how
expensive that team is
yeah just to see the you know get get to
see their faces like
like saying lorraine being the creator
of the halo logo and you know
putting a face to that which is such an
iconic logo for so many people
over multiple decades you know just to
see the face of the person that was
responsible for that was pretty crazy
but
yeah just some of the other reveals like
the weapons just get an idea of sort of
the general look and feel for some of
the legendary weapons coming
in beyond light hawk moon as well which
is
so yeah it was it was really good um but
they smashed it man
they doubled their their 400 000 from
the year before
and i think there's anything you can
count on is the community that surrounds
destiny just to come together for such a
great cause
and uh we you know it's disappointing
that we can't meet up next week
there's so many people we're supposed to
be we're just like everybody's getting
an extra drink next year because we're
missing this year so everybody gets two
years instead of one
it really okay we'll go back next year
man oh yeah it's gonna be huge
oh yeah we're going back we're gonna pay
it really hit me because i was just like
i was thinking to myself last week or
whatever it was i would have been at
coming back from e3 and then i would
have been prepping now
you know quick turnaround fly out to gcr
and
just i was look because now it's like
name to the face right and then
all these people and all you know we
interact with so much and
you know they're all going to be there
but like you said john you said it best
like it just means next year we're going
to go
super hard it's going to be that much
bigger and i can't wait man i can't wait
you got to come across the pond come
through man
all right now it's oh it's going to be
we'll go to charlie's we'll get a steak
you're going to have a couple of drinks
yeah it's going to be cool man
looking forward to it brother likewise
man
yeah so i mean that was they've had some
awesome ones so far
another one to shout out lupo last year
of course like dr lupo
if you guys got a chance when you go to
gcx when they do the whole ticket sales
again just make sure i can get one of
these tickets
as well buy the full vip
thing with the the night event
yes because it is worth going to if you
enjoy
laughing and having sore abs the next
day because it was
hilarious obviously can't say anything
about it that's the whole point
but we're understood we're stricken
[Laughter]
but like when it comes to like lupus
like has been part of this for a while
and last year
he absolutely crushed like he almost hit
a million last year
and to see what bungie did this time i'm
just like his
is gonna be sunday from i want to say
it's like eight to noon he's the last
block that sunday morning
and he went 30 minutes over last time
i'm honestly curious to see how much he
does this time
but to watch like any even any of the
community managers or deeds or you'll
see dylan in there just like
i mean people give him a hard time
sometimes for like you know snappy
reactions on twitter anything like that
yeah but it's just to see all of those
guys
every single one of them just yeah blown
away at what the community comes
together and does and they're just like
the numbers that we're putting up during
their stream are absolutely crazy
and i actually for you jarvis well
during that stream i was taking a
screenshot of
one of the two weapons it's either
hawkmoon or
the unknown legendary and when i took
that screenshot
your your donation was the one that
literally is up
in the corner of my screenshot it says
jarvis so it's like
well that's amazing timing so i have bro
i have proof you donated to the cause
perfect pop-up a very conviction that's
awesome
yeah i think it's important to do like
my oldest son was uh under great ormond
street hospital here in the uk
for quite a long time when he was born
he was born with a cleft palate so he
had like a hole in the top of his mouth
he didn't have the lip or anything but
he had the palate so he uh when he was
nine months old he had to have an
operation to plastic surgery in his
mouth to bring that together
um so you know to anything that can
support you know
the you know the care and support of
young children i i've sort of
we i've seen some of it you know here in
the uk being you know great much
almost we do some fantastic work um and
you know saint jude
you know again another global hospital
that does incredible work for
kids that absolutely shouldn't find
themselves in the positions they do
so anything you know it's a you know
it's a number
you know monetary value it's it is the
benefit it can have though and what that
means
for them is so much more to me than that
monetary values
absolutely brother he said it said it
well yeah i mean that that
that's the thing about the the community
and every year they just knock it out
the part we come together and it's all
for this great cause
uh it's it's tremendous that that's
probably one of the most
proudest things i am about being a
destiny fan and being part of this
community because
again i i i maybe i'm biased i just
don't see another community
is as invested and and doing all these
great things
as you know what bungie and and everyone
else you know in this part that's part
of
a concentrator whoever just coming
together all for a great cause i i've
i've never seen anything like that and
that's what makes me that's another
reason why besides the game being good
that makes us stick around you know
these these relationships these moments
you know you never forget these things
it's pretty pretty amazing it's just the
going back to even like the nepal
um you know yeah i almost donated
almost did that oh yeah that was that
was that
um shirt in the emblem but you know you
know those are small
things that have you know and you know
small little tokens i guess
for you know what's going to have a
major benefit to others around the world
and
we've proven it multiple times you know
guardians together as one will do
incredible things
absolutely i mean all the causes i mean
obviously we've seen the black lives
matter thing
you know lgbtq community i got my pen
came in the mail hey there you go
when it's in stock i got the old one i
got to get the new one now that's got
the
couple extra bars on it yeah on my side
it's one of my favorite emblems in the
game actually that pride mm-hmm
yes very cool i i use that's for my
because you know as a warlock i got to
match
you know subclasses to the emblem and
everything so you know
that's for my void that's my voidlock he
got that one because he got the purple
jean
you know whatever so yeah every subclass
i have to have a specific you know
ship sparrow and envelope you got it
it's all warlocks
it's you gotta you gotta coordinate
brother you gotta coordinate it
you're flexing you're flexing on it
speaking of merch by the way i got this
one what you got
oh oh oh oh that's that's the what you
call it
that's the sh oh that's the homie that's
that's the shacks that's the shacks like
artist
series one that they did i got that one
i tell you what i am still waiting for
i'm still waiting for that uh
that ghost oh yeah yeah
you know i got i've had about two emails
in the last year saying
it's coming but i haven't got it i've
got it in game um
it's it's the one that's got like hearts
it looks like a pandora charm
in game i think you actually get the
ghost in
like as a replica as well and i'm still
waiting on that
but know it all comes i guess
no doubt it will come in there it's like
everything is red or black or both but
yeah no it's like that's that's his kind
of scheme yeah
yeah i believe that he i'm thinking uh
black army was like
favorite content ever for stealthy so
shout out to that girl scheme
there's no question that was just that
had to be just like i live in scourge
now that's where i'm at
just here mm-hmm just getting that stuff
in i'm digging
what am i digging rivalry black sand i
think is my shader i used
um okay valkyrie what's it valkyrie
something from last season
the one for maximizing your bunkers
that's pretty cool as well
i like we're talking about this let's
get
to it we never we never asked anybody
like shader game like
you know favorites my fashion game is
trash so please do something better than
i do
my fashion game is ultra trash come on
you got to have some shades you got a
little style i'm sure
i can't remember names off top my head
right now at least but
yeah we got there's a couple of us man i
think for me um
what is it house of marine no i'm sure
yeah
i know you like yeah that one that's one
of mine's there's a um
there's a light blue one man that's so
clean that's for my um
for what i'm when i'm going ark when i'm
doing my my dragon ball z you can wear
that on your rope and you'll be camo
yeah yeah i do that a couple of calories
you know glow astropheric glow that's
like a black and green one that's pretty
cool
yeah i think everest i think everburst
had that for a short while
that's quite rare yeah man it's so it's
some real cool ones i i i like man so
yeah
boy got that reef made oh um
melchizedek something brown there's a
purple one you're talking about
that joint that hits yeah yeah that all
butter
nut that says monochromatic okay i like
that pure white
yeah i like that joy too and um the new
marquis shaded i i don't have it anymore
because i when i switched to piece uh
pc because i was from the old uh xbox
account
that their still shaders were really
cool man anything like red gold that's
for my solo yeah no i know so that's why
your new monarchy i know yeah
yeah yeah yeah i got you i know you
gotta i was gonna say so one i was
actually i pulled up dim right now to
look one of the ones that i like
because i like dark green of course i'm
going to lean towards gambit but i think
it's gambit celadon
um or gambit emerald both of those
if i can get a good dark green with like
some decent like accent like kind of
lighter green lines on it it's kind of
one that i definitely have
if i'm going to spec one out i've done a
couple of those for sure
because they're green so yes
it's dressed any after all man if you're
not if you're fashion games not to
scratch
we got ornaments now
transmog is gonna be so good can't wait
for that i will be curious to see on how
they handle
silver purchase versus what you gotta do
in-game because
it's not often they have both of those
quite the same so
true absolutely shout out to super dave
yeah
the new monarchy ones you stay there
yeah those ones hit hard man
i definitely miss those for sure you
just got to make sure you don't stand
out like you're wearing chartreuse down
a dark hallway you gotta like you gotta
have some
thought about like pvp colors you know
raining you can look as goofy as you
want in pvp
don't be bright yellow that's all i'm
saying oh yeah yeah yeah yeah over here
don't be bright yellow
okay the blue one is called frugalist
blue
shaded that you okay that one's probably
like straight up delete
what that's what it is that's my
legendary shard form that one
what that jewelry that hits man you
throw that blue with that little silver
to it
you got your arc subclass is right with
that man you got to throw that on right
there that's my joy
i say i go for looks i don't mind i'm
not i'm not as deep as like subclasses
matching my purse and my shoes with my
socks and designing my accessories yeah
i'm not that far i gotta i gotta step my
game up apparently so you gotta step it
up and the gun and the gun stop
and the gun okay what's your accessories
your accessories well you're a warlock
you got your own accessory you got your
little armband so you're good yes
salute especially that but uh we got we
got our dressed in these
segments excitement out the way so
what's been going on man what's going on
in the game
uh well season of arrivals is kicking uh
the contact public event moved to one
spot
still on the same planet so kind of the
first question to you guys as you're
going through that one
have you seen the mission for the week
and how long do you think we're going to
be hanging out on io so two questions
let's get out to joff uh yes i've done
the mission i've done it
twice so i thought i'd go back in there
and try and get out of bounds actually
but yeah i'd have done the
mission i'm loving those missions i
think um yes
it's tapping back into what like queen's
court did but also the uh
the six missions for eris and shadow
keep having that small reason to come
back every reset
and learn something new i think that's
really cool and just helps continue the
narrative through the season i really do
like
that they're starting to tell those
stories as the season goes by
um and the missions and they're not you
know they're fun to do solo like they're
actually quite challenging
even you know you know they're not easy
it's not just about running through it
you can't
so it's uh you know they're quite good
so i'm interested to see where they go
um and how many there are because you
get a piece of law every week for doing
it and there's like 13 or 14 pieces of
law
in that book so whether there's only
going to be a handful
or whether there's going to be as many
as that we'll have to wait and see
but yeah i think they're great and to
actually go to the
you know the cradle that we've seen from
a distance for so long
uh is is really cool too absolutely yeah
john you're on fire man i mean you
literally said exactly what i was
thinking i mean
i'm really digging the season structure
so far i know it's early i know you know
not that far in but it's just what you
said to me there's something to be said
as opposed to just you know doing a
public event a thousand times and then
going to
you know some you know location where
you
you know you kind of input stuff you
know similar to how like the bunkers
were
you know i think what's missing is that
story beat that connective and what i
like what they're doing is they're
giving us that mission
almost um season of the drifter
attempted
something like this with dessert thing
but i think this is just what
better just done executed better and i
loved going
and you also nailed it like i've been
soloing
you know the few times i haven't got a
chance a lot to play this season but the
times i've have always been solo
and i've been soloing a lot of having a
ball with it man i got my little
with the horde i got my um what what a
rocket in the energy i got my knowing
hunger
and i think i'm going one of them swords
um but i'm just
really enjoying you know it it's very
it's quite challenging like like you
said joff
you know it's a sense of accomplishment
when you do it and then you get that
narrative piece about what's going on
and stuff like that and i'm loving the
umbrella focusing i'm really liking that
as you know really kind of digging down
into getting into what specifically you
want so i think they kind of took a
little piece of
what was good from the menagerie and put
that into the whole
recasted thing i've been liking it man
i've been i've been really liking it so
far and um
you know the new thing that i'm i've
been doing is um
now that sun setting is a thing e
um i've been you're welcome that was
totally my doing it was just me
yeah like hey this should probably
happen he did it
that was the inside dig at eg
yeah it's been a minute but it was like
the week before the sun setting news
idea dropped
it was the friday before that like
tuesday or wednesday he did the
director's cut
i literally mentioned it should happen
we had this huge like knock down drag
out fight and everything
it was happening and then it was like
four days later i was just like you
might want to read this
yeah yeah he's like yeah it's happening
because i always feel like bungie
listens to ibonses like whatever
he suggests is best for the game really
not well
all of a sudden jarv the next twab it'll
be
stuff for the stuff he suggested and i'm
like oh
so anyway long story short at least my
exotics were saved so i'm i'm over it
but at the end of the day you know it's
it's been
interesting for me to go through my
vault look at
you know the power levels of certain
things get some reissues shout out to
the annoying hunting guy i re i
agree got with a nice roll okay so i
wanted to ask you about that
yeah because we're already seeing some
of the
reissues coming back where it's like i
have a gnawing hunger that i have
previously
and the one that i have that's older is
amazing like the one that i have already
if i'm going to go through and look
because i want to know
um just while you're looking on that
note i think a key thing especially with
the gnawing hunger because this is a
great example because it's everywhere at
the moment
yes the created role is really good for
pve
but you can't get that from the umbrella
engram
what's the creator role if you don't
like overflow rampage
so i've got yeah so i've got that on one
of the other seasonal
um or rifles but i don't think you can
get it from the amber engram
so for me personally like if i wanted a
pve roll i'll probably go for overflow
rampage personally
because you know i just haven't even a
magazine yeah
yeah and just mow it down but um but
yeah for pvp you can just
keep going until you get that kill clip
roll i guess but yeah
now for me i've been rocking the uh what
is it i've been a huge fan of the
subsistence rampage roll right now i'm
just been loving some systems just that
i feel like i'm just just keep on
shooting keep on killing keep on
shooting don't have to let go of the
button
shout out to cactus man he was
definitely putting me on to the
importance of yeah
he's got one with some stuff i love it
man knowing hunger is definitely
interesting but
your question as far as like how how it
feels like
for a couple like there's one or two
that i'm like that i sit there and see
and i think that's one of the bigger
like the i think
the sun setting is gonna allow them to
have like life of
like put breath into like some of their
newer stuff which is good
but when it's like these re-issues and
you're just sitting there staring at an
old one
that's the big argument i saw about the
reissues and i'm sitting here staring at
them
already this season like i've had one
and i was like
um just like yeah i just kind of curious
you guys thoughts on that stuff like do
you feel
that's just how the game rolls or like i
mean
let's get this job because i could go
guys
go first and then we'll open it i think
okay they're gonna reissue it
if they're gonna reissue it they need to
incorporate
more newer perks to go alongside those
because there's no point just farming
exactly the same role that you got a
year ago
just because you can now level that up
to the end of season four
or year four um because it's it made
your
original grind completely pointless if
you didn't have to go and do it again
could you say that sentence again i just
like how you your reflection with that
was just
really good you repeat that the the
whole the whole sentence you just said
god remember i said i'm just winging it
so
that's always getting that you nailed it
yeah so like yeah
like if i've got a rapid hit um uh
multi kill clip spare spare rations
comes back in that rotation with those
same perks available why
you know what's the point of having to
chase down the same weapon again
i mean i know power level is obviously a
thing but i'd much rather it come back
with newer perks they're the better
give me a reason to go after it again
not just to replace a weapon that i've
already got
that's probably what i'm trying to get
at no i agree i was just i was just
teasing it that was one of my arguments
against in the beginning was just
respecting player investment
and as far as the whole you know
especially i think you nailed it look
i'm over the whole legendary thing i'm
just being silly but the whole thing
as far as what you made a great point as
far as if they're going to do that
then at least like you said add
different more
add more perks to that perk pool so that
you're
you have a chance to get that knowing
hunger
you know in a way that you've never had
it before but to grind for the exact
same thing
just to bring it forward again you know
without any
changes it it is it's it's a hard pill
to sweat you know swallow so
for me yeah that's that's a thing that i
have to watch and
and to be honest i'm very surprised to
easepoint that
they brought it back they're starting to
do this so quickly
yeah yeah because it's not even tapping
into that nostalgia thing of oh
no hunger again like it's been you know
i mean i had one from like
two years ago it's not even there yet
because it's
literally i mean it's probably a year
since the scene is in the drifter but
it's quite clearly lot
not long enough right because 600 rpms
only really became
um meta i guess probably since uh just
after shadow keep yeah so
um yeah season of dawn so yeah i agree
man i think
too soon and if you are gonna do it have
more unique
newer perks in the pool and give us a
reason to go after it again
and then did you guys also see the raid
gear is going to season
14. yeah i'm happy for that man
do you think that's something do you
think that's long enough for what they
promised
or is because you got what is next years
12 13 14 and 15
so 14 it'll go away 15 and then we'll
get whatever the next transition is
that's
that will be probably the absolute
oldest stuff at that point
all of it will be gone going into 2021
nothing holds it so when you get to the
witch queen
that's it yeah yeah which queen yeah
like literally going to be beyond light
forward that's it yeah
yeah september is going to be kind of
cut off zones that's the problem
did you did you think that was going to
be longer i guess was the question
because you had
last wish you had i'm blanking right now
regardless of salvation garden of
salvation yeah i'm like thank you last
wish and gardner salvation and you had
last wish which was
fairly old still carrying forward and
you're like okay so if this thing's
gonna last like
our raid's gonna last like two or three
years and
it doesn't feel like it does it like
going whatever we get and say the
deep stone crypt rate deep stone crypt
raid not going into savathun's raid
seems like the raids don't i think
they're just
starting to chop the legs off of
everything now just waiting for those
yellow
yellow weapons to get the legs chopped
underneath them
easy easy sorry sorry i didn't i didn't
mean to say it out loud i should only
think those things i can't say about
that
the bungie listens why don't you stop
listening
[Laughter]
good to you
um i think i mean because they're
bringing back the uh
like leviathan armor and stuff like that
like
but that's also going away um with
beyond light so
some of the leviathan armor skirt drama
uh it's probably gonna be some of the
rarest armor
come the end of year four that's still
relevant i guess
in power so if you want to i mean i know
it's not the most
fanciest looking armor set in the world
but if you wanted something unique at
least towards the end of year four then
it's not a bad shot to do
and you know rerun those activities
before they go away
and get vaulted which would probably
come on to at some point as well but
it's
um i think it's good to have them i
think
uh leviathan is basically a destination
in itself right so
yeah you know with that they take two
raid layers with them as well but it
also removes all the very
very vicarious visions and high moon
content from the game
mercury's going mars is going live
going so all that sort of third
development
yeah it's gone all that activision
stuff's gone
it's just a bungee game again are we
implying this was a conscious decision
jarv
are we applying a clean break of divorce
like it is interesting right now to
watch some of these decisions like
you look at your weapons you kind of do
the math but it is also like we log into
season 11 where like
power level jump in the fall is 200
points
so we know that going in so when they do
something like hey you can see a year in
advance
as soon as we get to like season 13
we're gonna know i mean unless it's just
50 50
50 250. like if they've confirmed that's
what the power level is they
they've made it to that and that kind of
ties into
what has gone on in the past week we
talked about a little bit before the
patch that just happened the hotfix over
the umbrellas and leveling and that's
kind of what i want to talk to you guys
about next with
just with regards to the way the game
has been
thus far kind of the way the seasons
have been rolling we had the 10 points
in
undying or dawn 10 points in dawn which
was like
then we had 50 we got 50. now we're
going 200 which everybody kind of
expects with an expansion
but the whole leveling per season thing
which seems to have come
directly to a head due to the day one
dungeon
at 1060 situation wanted to get you guys
thoughts on just like the power level
grind where we're at
if there's changes you'd like to see to
it and then just kind of if there's
you know any pain points for you know
the casual university hardcore
it's a lot so just opening this up
let's get the expert in should i go fast
guess gets okay i'll say
it's got to come down to it as
accessibility so
locking content behind a exponential
power grind
is going to alienate some part of your
player base because
that's why the afk farm has become so
popular because we spoke about it
the dungeon is the biggest piece of fomo
they've added because it's going away at
the end of the season but it's also the
only place you can farm
high stat armor which is what you're
going to need going into beyond light so
if you've got a limited time window to
do that so that's why that's all popped
off i guess
in the way that it did but then to
address that is being able to go okay
well
you know nightfalls have multiple
difficulties multiple
uh you know buffs and debuffs and things
like that and
as a result they have various different
rewards on scale based on their
difficulty
so you can still have those activities
accessible at a lower power but you just
have the rewards relevant to the
difficulty of the activity
correct um so you're not locking
accessibility
you're locking you know player rewards
behind the harder content which is what
you'd want you if people that
work play the game more able to get
higher level
and complete harder activities should
get i guess the
you know the more rewards for doing that
but then you should also allow players
who aren't able to
grind up as much or don't have the time
investment to still
access those or be it get lesser rewards
they can still have that experience
yep um but if they you know but they
still need to put the time into it if
they want
the end game loot i guess that's that's
how i would look at it
as a possible alternative drive on fire
man it's
literally stealing points yeah look dude
i'm with you man i think that's a great
way because
like you said one of the worst things is
a newer player or not even a new player
let's just say
like this season for me just life has
gotten in the way i got a lot going on
you know with the podcast and stuff so i
just haven't had my
typical blaze sessions of non-stop
destiny all day when i want how i want
so
i've been lagging behind a big like i'm
like 10 30 something and i missed out on
the
unfortunately missed out on the farming
you know but whatever but um i don't
know
so it's fine yeah but you know it is
what it is so anyway but to your point
there's something to be said like okay
i'm looking at the dungeon i'm like man
like
you know because of the way life has
fallen i just can't
really participate until i get my light
up so what you're saying
really makes sense it's like you know
just like you're doing the nightfall
ordeal you know there's that
750 that effort and there's a different
levels of world you know who actually
did it well
i'm gonna say um reckoning number one
reckoning
the tears i believe each tier
had like a different length of time you
know before you i think tier 3 was the
one that
i think did the the complete bridge to
the boss or whatever whatever
but like if there's a way i don't know
if that's possible with every bit of
content but if there's a way you can
segment it great
if not then just continue to do what job
said which is like power level
and and reward equality based on the
level you know that you've picked
so the obviously the the hardcore guys
that are at the higher light
they get a chance at the higher rewards
and stuff like that and i think that
could help them you know i'm saying then
i'm having people isolated out of out of
content well yeah i i agree with that
he's got to go he's got a lean on
difficulty not just a
arbitrary number right so if you can
have like you have raids with contests
when they launch why can't that be
something we can just apply
across the board and that's applicable
to the fire team the average fire team
power whatever you know it creates
difficult content regardless of your
power level
um but you can still chase good rewards
there's multiple
things they could look at but you know i
think contest for raids at least should
just be an option
by default i want to we want to do
contests you know
you want to cap our power and you get
bonus rewards for doing it even if it's
double loop from the chest at the end
sounds like an easy thing but uh you
know for me i think that'd be pretty
cool when a lot of five teams would dig
that
absolutely yeah it's like the whole
contest thing i've heard way too many
people talk about
why that can't just be an option to be
like
normal contest and just gives you the
power level you know what it is doesn't
matter and you can even go back and do
like last wish on contest if you're
crazy
mm-hmm right yeah you probably couldn't
get the 24. yeah you couldn't get the
24-hour emblem
but maybe you could get a contest emblem
that's just sitting out there later on
if you go experience that content to be
like
all right how's this on day one you're
like holy crap and then so like you
really gotta buckle down gotta do it
first day strats all that stuff
there's no melting of bosses you gotta
do everything for real
gonna be a different feel to it and then
to your guys points as well it's like
when you take something like the dungeon
is interesting though and this is one of
those things i actually heard discussed
and i wanted to
kind of say on the other side of what
you guys are saying it's like
so do you so i guess i want to ask
before i go into mine
do you think the dungeon should be
accessible to everybody on day one no
matter their level
is that what you're kind of saying
i think i think it's how it was sold
like you know i think luke sold it as
you know you know there's a day's worth
of work in there to to get yourself
ready for it
i don't know anyone a day and about two
weeks ago
there were a couple people who were like
insanely high before that thing launched
but
like the average person that's not a day
the average person is
weeks of normal play schedule and life
not like gazillion bounties on every
character
and right hop it in with a three-person
fire team that can just wreck every like
strike nightfall go through do all these
things and like the average person it's
not and i guess like part of it is
the dungeon is still meant to be end
game which is why it's weird it launched
on day one now the fact that it's going
away
could have been the reason it launched
it yeah so that could have been part of
the reason to push and be like hey it's
out here
we're going to give as many people as
long as they can but again dungeons
aren't meant to be in game i don't want
pit of heresy to be like it's
it's weird i understand what you guys
are saying for like the easier
mode and the difficulty it's like hey if
you do it on easy mode and so you were
saying
what if you just did pit of harrison you
only had the necropolis
right yeah yeah that would be like kind
of a piece or the other side
you have a lower difficulty and maybe
when you do pitoversy
there's less enemies there's less adds
coming at you in the chamber of
suffering
they could do those types of things to
like an easy and hard
and those are three ways to do it which
honestly some of that stuff i missed
from destiny 1 when we had like
normal and hard mode raids like still
like that's the epitome of they made it
hard and they're like okay let's pull
this this this this out and like this is
the normal mode
and then we add in like the ultra like
the the full built mechanics back in for
hard and you're like oh right
let's add some champions in there you
know let's make it really difficult
yeah harder difficulties and stuff like
that i think yeah
and i guess like i was going to say in
any other pieces but it looks like what
i want to see and that's what jarv said
is
i want the rewards to go with that stuff
as opposed to reach
like you go into pit of heresy and
you're like you finish the pit of heresy
you can do it solo flawless doesn't
matter how you do it but you beat that
thing especially even when you did it
they still in a year have not fixed the
fact that that gear at the end
drops masterwork to like mid 60s at best
and it's like it's i'm like i'm getting
a 52 stat roll
yeah the energy is nice so i can use
mods but i'm like that thing ought to be
sitting at like 79 or something when i'm
done not
64 and i'm like losing my mind
so i just like because stats is one of
those things that they seem to be
you know that's part of the armor grind
if you're gonna do something like pitta
pharisee
you know guarantee high stat rules and
they're doing a little bit of that with
the umbral but i think
more of i for the leveling progression
this is why i can ask you guys first so
i'm gonna
go on my little spiel part of what we go
through is like hey so if you do
basic stuff vanguard strikes now we get
a pinnacle right now which is weird but
it helps you level it's fine but if you
do vanguard strikes maybe your armor
that drops in there is like
i don't know low 50s at best
then you can go into nightfall and like
as you go up in difficulty it starts to
show like
the stat range that the armor can drop
at it's like normal
hero legend master and like if you do a
master nightfall
you're seeing like you know average
stats like 64 to 68
if you do legend at 60 and you can see
like there's a reason to go after that
because you're actually getting
better benefits in there and the one
thing i wish they would do is like
hey if i do a master nightfall in some
of these true in-game pieces to say like
take the dungeon
the people who want to do it on hard
mode could say hey this piece of armor
i want them to just mess with the system
be like yeah this has 12 energy slots
instead of 10.
i want them to like give those
difficulty steps
so that's the idea
oh sorry i was reading something in chat
when you break
when you break down pit of armor you
should have a chance of getting a golf
ball
that wouldn't be bad i think so yeah i
mean i spent that to
master work here i mean you spend three
on an exotic and you don't you never get
it back
so would you guys just curious on that
whole rambling spiel
no i i hear where you're going um
there's a lot of validity there
obviously
you know i think the point you're also
making in reference to
i think it does have to be some leveling
build up to like for example
you should throw an example you know i
do feel there has to be some leveling up
to get to that easy mode version of what
we are trying to aspire for
right right so they still have to be
some you know obviously
you know you got to respect player time
so i i i'm of the mindset
don't necessarily give it as soon as the
game launches
i think in this case we're like you said
we're in this unique situation
where they're about to transition to a
vault system
to all these new systems on the back end
that's going to start in september
so probably in their mind they're like
look this content we're going to have to
break normal
protocol where we would give this in the
middle of the road map of the season
and now we have to give it earlier to
maybe compensate for that system
so i think that there's probably an
exception to the rule but um i'm with
you
i i i don't have any problem with a
little bit of ground with that or
like you said like a subsection you know
for that easy mode and then you know you
go
higher and higher and stuff like that
that that feels good
i think ultimately what you're saying
the main point what you're saying that
are really
really resonating with me is definitely
you know
those that end game content when you're
doing tier three
or whatever that done you know that that
stuff you need to be
those stat roles that that needs to be
high
like those masterwork materials they
need to be showering you
now we've seen them going in the right
direction with trials and stuff like
that now
you know each win you get more and more
like it's the same thing you have to
respect
investment and rewards it's okay to give
this stuff out because the reality is
there's not a lot of
sources where they are giving it out so
yeah i'm with you
i'm i'm i'm cool with all that yeah just
crazy was
grand master and styles both like i mean
we have two pinnacle activities with
man rewards and you're like yeah i know
some people are going to go through for
the concord title totally get that you
want the challenge that's there
but for the average player to even
consider it's like did i really want to
go for it i mean to
i might do i might go for conqueror this
season mostly for the fact because i
know sun setting is happening in season
12.
but no i've got access to my entire
arsenal
whatever's best at the time has a chance
to help me get through it
but other than that like there's not a
better item there's nothing
there's nothing that in the hardest
stuff that makes you better and coming
from
too many games like hey you do a
division thing this thing has a higher
set of stats you do a world raid you're
like
hey this is a like ultra level gear
whatever it's when you do the hardest
stuff we should be getting higher and
that's something i hope they embrace in
the fall
we just have no idea if it's coming yeah
i agree i i
definitely definitely hope they do that
that would be really cool i think they
looked at difficulties with dungeons
because from the
database i think the heresy had multiple
difficulties right
they just never put it into the game for
whatever reason
how that would transmit for loot i have
no idea i think um
it's a careful one though isn't it
because if you have multiple
difficulties
and i guess i know have lower tier stats
for easier difficulties and higher tier
stats for higher difficulties than
the better players that can invest more
titles take better players the ones that
can invest more time and power level up
to those harder difficulties
will only get better whereas ones that
can't play the game as often
won't get good stuff so it has to come
down to chance which is obviously r d
based i guess but you have better
chances of getting said stuff right
right by doing harder stuff
um because you can't because otherwise
you'll end up with two massive pools of
players
where right you know veteran players
hardcore players just get better and
better and then
new light you know and new players
casual players
you know fall along the wayside and
that's no fault of their own but
it's striking out balance that's a
balance that's bungee you've got to try
and strike and it's not an easy one for
sure it's it's not an easy one and to
your point job that's why i always
champion like when we talk about stuff
like that with trials specifically
when i talked about they had needed to
bring that bounty back
because as a person who wasn't going to
the lighthouse often
me you know i said like i looked forward
in d1 that
that trials bounty that i would get a
shot at doctrine or passing or some
higher level there was a percentage
right there was a chance so every year
that i played
i got a shot at least trying to attempt
to get one of these higher level weapons
that might only drop you know more
consistently
you know if i went to the lighthouse
which i wasn't so i think that's
where they can also mess and try to
strike that balance so that you give
you always want to give that new light
player
a little hope you don't want to
discourage them right because if you
just give them the worst rewards and the
worst thing then
what's the sense of coming back because
everybody else is outshining you you're
not going to be able to
you know really compete so i definitely
think there always has to be a little
bit of rng
and then you increase percentages as you
go
up you know to really you know has to
always be that chance right yeah it just
gets
that chance just grows but i was like
also in
on the other side let's go apparently my
apparently i'm devil's advocate today
that's my job
let's go let's go uh adept weapons
you're going to put those in a flawless
chest that's not something the average
person is going to be able to get
that's not for the other player that's
not for them that
you got to get to the land this is the
best of the best that's literally my
point then if you're saying
you literally just said you got to give
them a chance to get that high level
stuff
i agree then you turn around and say
that's only for the high level people
so which ones i hear your point but
here's the thing they're still getting a
chance at the weapon
they're not going to not get the weapon
at all the adept is just adding like an
additional
person which is not going to change
i can't feel sorry for you that you i
mean for that person
who is like yo i got the gun but i also
should get the adept version of it
when this guy went to the lighthouse and
you just doing a bounty every week
and that's sorry that's that's the but
if i
if you don't say anything it sounds like
okay so everybody needs a chance to get
everything
maybe even if it's just like a 10 roll
versus a 90 roll
they have a chance to get the same item
it's like in my mind you can get
a maybe a variation but that person who
does that elite level
does fall flawless card does the master
nightfall does the pit of heresy
if you solo flawless if i if there was a
chance to do a solo flawless bit of
heresy
every week and you would be guaranteed
some stupid crazy good drop
you know i'd be doing it but again you
do it one time and it's like a checkbox
but after that it's kind of trash
but it's like again if you do those
types of things
you need something that sets it apart
from what the average player could go
for because the skill needs rewarded
that's right yeah it needs to look
different and maybe feel different to
use but in terms of his output the
output needs to be
consistent i guess otherwise yeah then
you just create those two paws or
players again
like you say snapshot doesn't really do
much in terms of uh
output from the weapon but in terms of
look and feel
you know the weapons look different and
they felt different to use slightly
because of that
i start on snapshot but yep um
yeah you could tell someone went
flawless i think that's the probably as
good as balance as you're gonna get
yeah you need to you need to respect
people that are able to go to the
lighthouse but also allow people that
aren't
to get the weapons albeit a different
version
exactly i mean i think another point is
like i said the aesthetic
that has to happen because that then
shows the time investment that shows wow
how did you get you know why does your
gun look that way you know what i'm
saying as opposed to mine
because transparency so that's the first
step
then the second step which i don't feel
breaks the game when we talk about the
adept stuff
and we all like you know what else did a
a good job when we did sundial and when
you
you maxed to the sundial and you got
that extra
perk to choose remember that was
time yeah that was more time
but again then you take on the other
side there was a hard difficulty and
there was zero point
yeah well we know they messed up with
that you know but that's like that's
where they could
try and put something in there yeah
exactly that's what we'd agree with so
i'm just saying
i like that as an example of things you
can do so again
the weapon whether it be patron of the
lost causes
or breach light or whatever these
weapons we were farming right
you know the guy that really put had the
investment all season he was going in
he gets a chance for that double perk
pool whereas the guy who you know didn't
have as much time he still could get the
weapon though you know what i'm saying
that's all i'm trying to say
yeah i just thought it's the whole idea
of a participation trophy feel
and that's the one thing i worry of you
take away the reason for the person
who's
skilled or like puts teamwork together
and grinds the hell out of like
you know they do level all season they
finally put it together they run the
flawless bit of hair they run the pit of
heresy
or this season they do a flawless solo
prophecy so i was trying to think of the
word and again they get a random
widow's bite sniper with crap rolls or
something it's like
something needs to be put in there for
the the ultra efficient like i mean i
know aries he's trying to solo flawless
i'll do it once my level and
last of us two's out of the way and it's
those types of things need to
need to have something in there for the
aspiration to go for absolutely but we
i think we could still meet both of our
missions with what you're saying
but i think we're we're literally on the
same page the mission still
gets there with with the the person that
doesn't have
the time investment versus the person
who was really going hard
i still think it gets there with both of
these suggestions we're talking about
and both both
bases aren't pieced sorry not trying to
like belabor a point
so no no no we just love to be on the
like
player investment team at bungie and b
now these are the meetings they've
probably had that's a lot
of they're literally like because
they're literally duking out well we
have 90
of the people who are new like casual
and then you have this 10 who's loud and
barking over here
right right and then the investment
team's like well how do we balance those
and that's
you gotta honor both sides because the
hardcore drags the new people in like
oh what's this giant why is destiny
giantly up on twitch stream
it's a big raid release day these people
are awesome doing crazy things
did they get anything good no yeah or
yes
and that's you can have two different
reactions from that so
agree as long as it's not two takers in
a blue man
i think we're good burn burn burn i'm
with that
i'm with that
wow i don't know how to recover from
that one bunch of you okay
public event rewards ever
so yeah and then we saw
so we had the gcx stream and we saw a
teaser for two things one
the red and blue crazy looking weapon
have you do you have a thoughts of what
that is
jarv what are we thinking um
i don't really know to be honest i think
it's it could either be
i mean potentially there's some
pulsing or rifle themes or feels on i'm
looking at it but it could possibly even
be
a shotgun it's really hard to yeah
that's what i was leaning towards
actually
shoddy really yeah main reason
when you look at it i'm trying not to
ruin the stream right now
so if you look at the black goofy
looking
thing on the blueberry it's like your it
would sit here
and then it looks like where you would
insert the shells underneath
and this is where you'd like [ __ ] and
load the shotgun and the rest is just
like the big brace but i don't know why
it's that's what i was like for a sec at
first i was like it's a sniper and then
i've honestly switched the thing into
the shotgun
it has a really really like large barrel
large barrier so unless it's like tiny
but it looks long so then it has a like
large opening for a barrel which i think
shotgun but then on the other side it
has a very long
rail up top and this little scope in the
back and i'm like which made it feels
like
it's somebody said like at first sniper
shotgun like
a weird combo thing i'm like i don't
know what it it it feels like a shotgun
by like the underneath rail and the size
of the barrel but then let the top
it's just it's weird so i'm really
curious what that is
but the other one and even dabo made his
video about it already
hawkmoon
and it's the truth is complete yeah the
truth
is completely true it's not gonna be the
same as it was
they're gonna mess the randomness of how
the gun works they said it's like it's
not gonna be damage related
um but it will be coming back so i was
just kind of curious what you guys
thoughts of
of another d1 return is a good one for a
turn
so what do you think well that all
talked about it uh
let me jump this one off yeah this is a
fun one
if you don't i haven't watched this
video yet
okay i'll watch it a little bit later
that's that's cool um
it's hard isn't it because those are the
unique things those are the things that
made
hawkmoon unique so it's uh
when they reprise something it needs to
be an evolution of its uh
former self not a war or down version so
it's it's finding
that balance i mean by the sounds of
what luke was saying it still feels like
they're experimenting with what feels
right and i guess a little bit
can be seen when you look back at like
ariana's vowel originally you set itself
on fire and they scrapped that and made
it an ornament and put it on
tommy's matchbook instead you know so
yeah they'll
they'll mix and match different things i
just don't know how they're going to do
a hawk moon really because
it needs to do increased damage because
that's what made it special but
taking the randomness out and mento mori
is the closest thing to taking out
randomness
um that also provides damage buffs as
well
but you don't just want another ace of
spades that's a different
rpm hand cannon right so it's um
yeah man i'm i'm interested to see it
i'm i wanted to use it i hope it sounds
just as awesome as it did
oh that sounds so clean oh
that's the way that big shoots that's
all the thing yeah that was a very clean
sounding
yeah you get that luck in the chamber
and that whoa
it was it was clean it was clean yeah so
yeah man it's
i get i get taking a randomness out
because you want to take rng out of
gunfights generally but
it's uh yeah memento mori is probably
the closest thing i could probably say
to achieving that but yeah
this is a this is a fun topic because uh
i i
i had the pleasure of watching dados uh
video on this which is absolutely
hilarious i
feel for him as a person we all have our
favorite exotics that's just how things
are with destiny you have those
attachments
and for him hawkboon is that so you know
he's been a
staunch proponent that it needs to come
back in
its original form and the lore you know
i mean you know a side with it which was
the whole
magic bullet right that's what made
hawkmoon special there was always that
chance it's like hitting the slots
playing live you know you there's that
[ __ ] that chance that that that bullet
would be you know that two tap get him
out of there and it was just a magic
thing so um
i feel him however um
bungie doesn't seem to be going in that
direction they've alluded that there
will be some type of evolution or change
to the gun
you know i'm at this point i'm willing
to give them
the way i look at it is i look at it as
thorne when thorn was announced coming
back
i was terrified i'm not going to lie to
you john i was like oh no
not that good not that i didn't want it
to come back but if i
yeah like if it came back in its
original d1
form the terror that gun reigned on
people
i i i i was scared i was shook up so
to see their evolution of it and then
they had the little orbs and then the
thing and then the power up and it's
still
effective it's still really good i think
dawn is a good example
of them evolving it in a good way
where you still keep the basic feel and
the premise of the weapon
albeit slightly changed from d1 so now
hawkmoon um yeah like i'm happy with it
coming back
um i'm very curious to see how
they do you remove luck in the chamber
completely like how you you do you do
you remove
bonus damage like you could adapt the uh
lumina
thing can you wear it like you get a
kill it creates some sort of orb that
you pick up and then your next round is
uh
a bucket to your your damage rather than
a bullet for you to buff others it's a
direct buff to you
and you see that crazy i don't know
didn't that crazy number
yeah i loved the way that gun first off
i love the way the gun felt so i'll be
very curious to get it back because that
thing for
year one it just felt good whether i had
the numbers and i could hit my shots or
not just the way
it felt so good always you're not a
haircut a guy like that so i'm impressed
that you like talking
like this oh no like that was that was
my baby in year one hawkmoon i lived
oh no oh i know was one of my d1 babies
for
as long as as when it had its life
because i mean i was playstation so i
got to enjoy it
sorry speaking of which i was just about
to comment i was xbox i know
you didn't even know about the magic i
never when i got hawk
totally different good could you go into
the castle even just as
a hand cannon for me it was always one
of my like some people were like oh it's
highest luna or this and even when is
luna was top i still loved my hawkmoon
feel for me and this was like for me i
hate
uh trust i cannot stand 180s for some
reason some people love trust and
a 180s just don't feel right they don't
hit hard for you or it just
it's either the animation or the recoil
or the something about it like the
numbers i see i'm like oh they're doing
pretty good damage but it's just like
the way the gun moves almost it's weird
it's one of their bungie feel things
feel things i'm one of those who doesn't
jam with
like trust i could do other weapons but
no malfeasy for you huh no
malfunctioning
it's the vehicle recall the perfect
vertical recoil like i like it when it
sort
comes off to the side a little bit and
you can sort of like
get your shots on when yeah i don't know
what it is it's the same
like service revolver i've got some
great roles in it yeah i don't like
like service revolver and uh now trust i
feel you something about trust
i'm with you on that but service
revolver
actually it was malfeasance that really
got me into 180s
i love this joy but a shout out to cb
gray he's like you don't like what 80s
either so wait
so what do you prefer you before 150s or
oh
i mean 150 just pretty much not a 180.
i'm just no i'm serious like i'll use
all of these things with that
i've used a duke and messed around with
it like 140s
but i'm giving what ted's more love than
180 just the way it for a feel
and i'm saying this is me being stupid
i'm not arguing
this is you but it's just like when i
fired trust i was like
it just never felt it felt good to be
and i can never explain why everybody's
like oh dress is so good i'm like
i feel so terrible it was always so odd
to me
oh my god one ten slam tens thank you cb
110s make them great
so you bust out the duke you was like
all right this is what i'm talking about
if i can hit duke shots they feel good
yeah
oh my god the slander 180s okay
it is a personal thing man dude i have
like five dukes in my vault
they're all good probably i need to
delete a few like everything i like to
i do like do but continue continue so
we're back to the hawkmoon and
obviously the the aesthetic we can
if it feels good and the perk the way
they choose to mess with the perks
that might be an exotic ornament i buy
just because it's one of mine some like
one of those like that might be a sucker
moment for me
mm-hmm ten dollars here we go yeah
make them cheaper and i would buy them
all i'm serious if it was like
if i could spend like 10 bucks and get
three things as opposed to 12 bucks for
one
i'll spend 20 to get six and then i
would absolutely spend 20. so it's like
that's a whole different discussion but
no i'm very i was surprised to see it
announced
honestly because for one we always have
way too many hand cannons anyway
so to get that another one i was like
here we go again but
it was it has a special place so i will
be curious if they ruin it or not
so you know what's funny like good job
i was gonna say if you could reprise an
exotic and pull one out of the vault
that wasn't hawkmoon what would your
go to be what would you like to see come
back from destiny1
yeah uh i need a list hold on
google treat me well here destiny
exotics
hold on i gotta scroll
getting that scroll on going back into
the digging in the crates
digging in that folk digging in that d1
vault
what are we looking at i'm looking
touching last time
really if they read if they revisit it
just redo it
you know i'm saying but um what about
what did you got one cognata what are
your what are your
d1 jams most of them have come back so
for me
you know i'm just not the best phrase
there i've got most of them back in d2
because they didn't make new stuff up
we can't give them slander because we
ain't going to act like we're the horde
ain't out here ruling these streaks
all right so let's give out the new
credit but yeah
true but where the heart is with the
horde that's a new exotic so
you know this is for the ogs but um i
think for me like i said i got sleeping
bag
last word obviously you know what i'm
saying that's one of my favorite um
there's some weird ones that i i miss
just for weirdness sake
um i definitely what was the uh hey i
want to forget the name of it the
the arc kinetic
supercell zelo yeah yeah yeah i i
i like that i had a little little jay
glass i used that a lot of nightfalls oh
man did i ever
yeah i missed elemental primaries i
missed him so much so that was one that
that set it off i got a weird one since
we talking 110s
i don't know how they would do it but i
i like the power
it was a not used exotic remember first
curse
yeah blue first card i never
never got much love but yes i did
remember it it it did it it had maybe
like one buff
it hit like a truck but it was it was
definitely not the
the fastest handling thing but uh you
know that that's it and then probably
the last thing see i got y'all got
sleeper
i got all my og stuff kind of back
you know so i what about what about you
um
drive like any bring
there's literally like a handful that
haven't made it back right you got like
gala horns not come back obviously
silo is just it's not not that different
to a risk runner now really the red
deaths like crimson so there's a lot of
similarities with some weapons i think
the and then
obviously you got the ones with ammo
regenerating perks they don't come back
so the only one that isn't one of those
really that hasn't come back yet
is possibly vex mythoclast as a as a
possible one
don't don't tease this man with that bug
don't don't tease this vodka
it's coming it is
exactly come on that's like you know
peanut butter without the jelly like me
come on
you know what's happening he's like so i
got two which you got let me hear you uh
patience and time because i always like
the clothes going cloak that was good
now this is something i wish they would
do
class specific ones like talalock
that was my jam and that's like
it works the way um
what is the hollow fire heart by not
using your super you get benefits
otherwise then this is one of those
while your super is like full up that
gun was a
monster but by doing that it was like
freaking auto scout it was just crazy
town but
you also sacrificed the way that gun
plays
you can't use your super to have that
effect so it was a trade-off so
those are ways for them to try and get
some uniqueness in there to be like hey
if you want to use this sub
you know your super or you can have a
gun that fires like crazy
like those type of pocket infinity by
the way
just that's almost merciless but still
um i think it broke the game didn't it i
think they they'll break the game again
yeah can it be worse than telesco though
no
they just look at telesto when a server
shuts down so
i think that's how that goes you're
right over there you got like
construction going on
yeah it's bad bro they're literally
doing construction right now it's
bad yeah sorry it's fine we'll keep it
going so um
but yeah so there are some cool ones i
just you know we
we have seen if you guys have actually
looked at the beyond light page
they show two exotic kind of gear
pieces of gear at this angle one might
be a rocket launcher one might be
a weird looking like serrated sword
i don't know if you guys have seen those
but if you go to that page it's just
below stasis
they get some cool looking ones coming
so definitely got some new ones coming
in the fall as well but
yeah just need some love man oh my god
how would you fix rocket launchers i'm
curious what would you do just
more damage faster fire two in the
chamber
all i think having more in the chamber
initially i think having one you know in
the chamber kind of sucks
or even have the option to get tripod
back or something like that that was
quite a cool perk
um and they need to buff the damage
anyway from it
even if they have like some sort of uh
debuff on the enemy
like uh you know bell winter's helm
gives if you have the opportunity to
to do that with some perks you know so
it increases the damage of
other weapon types not heavy weapons
yeah cause that would be overkill
um you know that can you can stack with
other things
it's a hard one um because you don't
want to
you know you can't keep just moving the
bar up and up in terms of damage numbers
because then uh you know you've got that
creep going on again
but um at least have more in the chamber
because you know having to reload every
time
automatically makes them not optimal for
any dps build
because just forever reloading the thing
especially after
you know the nerf to things like luma
boots and stuff like that so you can't
just stand there and fire it
yep so yeah that'd be the uh the
standout change initially to see how
that feels and then maybe tweak some of
the numbers
outside that yeah it seems about fair
yeah just a damage boost yeah it's like
they're just so
slow you can fire one and for that two
seconds you're like cool and then dps
just falls off a cliff and you're never
coming back
so it's pretty rough on that front
someone's already killed what you were
trying to shoot with a sword anyway so
especially with the mods
[Laughter]
um so yeah like exotics
continue to be fun i guess we'll see how
they go but yeah hawkmoon
uh i had had a special spot so we'll see
how it plays out i guess
um and then i didn't know time to
explain it's coming back right
so yes that's the one i'm actually
excited for
low key i felt that what it has
potential that we need to see more
critical hits is that what it did in the
end
that sounds yeah precision hits are used
to refund the magazine
yeah so it used to be good for like
golgoroth and stuff like that
main body shots to gain bonus damage on
your next precision shot and return ammo
to the mag so it's kind of like a
jade rabbit pulse almost to a point
the way at least it sounds there
i don't know are you are you just dying
over there sir
[Laughter]
oh do you if you guys are listening i've
muted it do you hear this
can y'all hear it yeah when you're
talking i can't see you it's insane
it's insane they're like yo you know the
podcast
jackhammer let's go i'm like come on bro
it's bad well hey at some point if you
got to talk that's just part of it
there's
for the audio listeners out there
cognito has apparently got jackhammers
outside
roofing being done and apparently
they're just ripping out one of his
walls
he's shaking his head over here yeah the
look of disappointment oh it feels man
need to get that rtx voices you can you
can make that work on the gtx card
right here you can send me the link i'm
gonna buy it
this is awful continue rtx voice on gtx
card
yeah i need to show him that i haven't
even tried that on mine yet i've got a
1080 ti i didn't know it actually would
do that
yeah i use it when i'm like discord but
if i'm doing commentary
i i have it like fresh from my mixer i
don't have it on and
makes sense that's about it really yeah
um yeah we do have another patch coming
down the pipe uh so we got one patch
we got you know antes wards the remove
super energy bonus and increase sprint
time to activate so you still got your
still bubble of protection but
a little harder to just walk around a
couple fixes
just across the board nothing too major
trials will return today so if you guys
are open for trials you got it coming
back
and then um they they they took a few
beavers out not all of them they just
introduced a minor fix for beaver errors
so
hopefully you guys will be seeing less
of those that's a constant thing but
yeah i was like the 12 was actually very
light this week there wasn't a ton
obviously the donations were insane they
got another patch coming for the
controller remapping options where
the the controller remapping was good in
theory and they broke sprint
they broke it it was awful
uncontrollable
like i don't is it brutal is it just if
you like sneeze the wrong direction your
sprint's over
dude you you try to spread like more
than once you're just stopping it like
interrupted every minute it was
awful brutal uh they're gonna fix the
wither hoard deals excessive amounts of
damage that's gonna be
planned for next week they're finishing
up some testing so don't know if it's
gonna be tuesday they'll probably shoot
for it so look for that twitter hotfix
notification uh fixing issue where solo
completion of prophecy does not unlock
the triumph
hopefully that one's retroactive
hopefully
and then um yeah a couple other things
beyond light pre-order bonuses
like i got the beyond light collector's
stuff
separate no game and then i'm gonna do
the digital blocks on steam
oh you're doing a stranger statue
is that how you get no i don't think
it's a separate bundle i think
yeah that's a separate thing on top so i
got the one because i got the pyramid
segment i got the pyramid fragment one
that's the one i wanted
but if they email you so i got the one
with the game
and they email you the code and then you
just put it in steam straight away so
when i go to test and look in my uh
expansions tab i already own beyond
light when i look at that
i just did them separate i probably
could have done them together that's
fine but
just trying to make sure i didn't have
to wait on them like shipping me a
stupid steam code in the mail or
something
here's an actual desk yeah it's like i
don't even have a
freaking cd-rom drive remember that
so much yes good old days of disk
but the statue is insane the amount of
detail on
statues i want one they're a limited
supply though i don't know
how much they are either they're not
gonna be cheap if it's like any of the
others you can go
anywhere from 150 to probably 300 was
usually if they're that type
they're never they're never cheap
they're legit though
every one of the like the models that
they do they look so detailed and good
yeah
but yeah we got the confirmation about
the raid armor not make making it past
season
14 so you know season of the worthies
year four counterpart is the last time
you'll be able to use that
just when interesting they wouldn't take
it to 15. they cut it like
three months instead of just hey you get
one more year and then it's out it's
like
what is going on in season 15 that you
can't use right gear
it's always some always wonder just like
why there's these weird arbitrary
numbers out
there you think maybe the promotion of
the the new one they just really
you know was it deep stone [ __ ] well
yeah i mean deep stone crypt you'll be
able to use the old raid stuff in
because that'll be september
but i mean unless they do season 12.
yeah that's just season 12. then 13 and
14 you'll still be able to use it that
rate will still probably be active the
way garden is now
that rate will still probably work in 15
but your gear won't
so maybe that's the way to be like hey
that old stuff okay
now you really got to forget about it as
we go into the fall like the summer's
the summer's the transition time maybe
they're just making it that
yeah that's what it feels like that hard
cut off as far as that's when
september seems to be a refresh a renew
and then you know a lot of the old stuff
go goes at least that's the vibe i'm
getting yeah yeah that gives you that
season to
get relevant gear to take into fall
rather than
carry what you've already been carrying
all year into the dlc
it's sort of what we're doing right now
which is why um rams are really good and
being out of focus their
specific stats is really really good
yeah it'll be nice to go for truly like
high stats and
everything we're going when that's when
finally the prismatic recaster gets like
maxed out
it's going to be nice it's going to be
rather pretty
let's see what pops out of there i mean
seeing some of the stat rolls coming out
of the dungeons insane i know say no to
rage had a pretty nutty
like 113 stat piece of gear come out of
there
70 plus what would you have to have like
powerful friends for 20. so that would
take it maybe to like 90.
you had powerful friends traction and
like a mobility mod on there i think
yeah that would be bonkers
shout out to isi he cleaned out his
whole vault everything maxes out 1060.
yeah i did the same thing man
some things i i couldn't delete because
i think it was like
my galleon i was like oh i can't there
was something i was just like i can't
there's this role i think my boy got the
um
the curated um kindled orchid i could do
it
well i mean yeah some of those things
see
i mean i have a [ __ ] problem
but some of those things
they get to stay yeah because i'll be i
was looking at all my voice all right 10
60s
come to the front it was like we're
doing a little execution little chopping
block
you nah yup you so a lot a lot of people
got thrown in you know throw it into
your abyss
delete it but there was something that
i'm like i just cannot in good
conscience delete this gun
i just can't uh and the orchid was one
um i was like i was gonna ask protocol
stuff
yeah i was to say like my curated nation
of the beast that i just like
luckily god yeah keeping that one
because that was like the how i finished
my solo flawless there's certain ones
for me that i have like
certain like memories for i still have
my whatever kinetic sniper it is
which one dread adventure it's the one i
used when i did my whisper the worm run
and just have the arm and it's it's
rapid hit rampage so it's actually a
pretty good roll
um but yeah that thing is sold
it's not going forward but it's not
getting deleted either but then i sit
there and look at like
oh i've got an imperative with outlaw
and multi-kill clip
appended mag extended barrel and i'm
like if scout i can't tell you if
i've honestly thought about just
deleting every scout rifle i know right
we're like
every scout rifle right now i look at my
vault and i'm like do you
why do i even have you does everything a
scout honestly for me literally because
i see night watch dropping like i
watched all is good though i like that
watch i do
but it's this was it actually i was
trying to remember what gun i have that
i'm like
why um
why is there like something that pissed
me off that dropped this season
that i already had oh my night watch
that i already have
rapid hit multi-kill clip range
masterwork full bore
oh i already have that from drifter and
now it's dropping now
not gonna hold up yeah i know i
i had to delete my you at one of my like
match the world same thing i had like a
rapid hit multi-kill clip night watch
ma and then i literally got the new
version and i'm like with the same role
pretty much
and i'm like oh all right come to you
got to get the old one out delete get
got you got a bunch of shards though got
a bunch of what you call it all right
that's that's where the reissues have to
be very careful for
what they're doing with them because if
they if that happens frequently it's
gonna start to piss a lot of people off
who are around
but if they make things like the trinity
google catalyst i'm probably not gonna
care
have you got that yet you probably don't
have that yet do you
i've got the catalyst have you finished
it yeah i've been working i've heard
it's i heard it's
nutty have you used that jarv have you
used the trinity google with the
catalyst on it
no no i do have the catalyst it has
dropped i just haven't got it but i've
seen some of the videos and it's uh
it's a change grind
as soon as i got that exotic i threw it
straight before i've never even tried
trinity ghoul i've been terrible i tried
it a little bit
yeah the only boy i tried was lemon
which i did like but continue yeah that
one's fun
um mm-hmm so what it does
is you bring it in i'm trying to find
the wording on it so i say it right
educate me on this gun i deleted
that's what collections are for you can
always pull it back out
basically what it does is you know the
if you get a precision kill
when the like a precision kill when you
get the full draw and all three little
shots are together because you know it's
three arrows not one
yeah right when you get the precision it
used to be you had to get a precision
kill with trinity google to activate the
lightning coil
and then when you'd fire the three and
you could spread them out how much you
wanted
and it would shoot lightning down if you
have that gun
equipped not put away but equipped
arc damage just damage
activates lightning coil grenade
super just like
it is it is insane
so it's like what it will do any art
so any arc damage final blow you do a
grenade you do a super
you do this one you get a grenade this
final blow this final blow so you if you
do the lightning
i could i sat there in altars of sorrow
just
because you would just shoot one guy the
lightning would come down on top
and then as you and then you don't even
have to get precisions you can just
spread them
and get the spread every kill it gets to
be
lethal it is so like if
they if they refresh older exotics
like that yeah now we're talking
because that's what i'm saying oh and
that's that's like
that exotic that gives that one brand
new life
this is what i'm talking about this is
why i say save the exotics baby this is
what you do
look how you look how you're raving
about i know the guy you're raving about
this old exotic that you wanted to kill
off i was like
if there's more of this yeah that's a
different story but this is like a baby
of the first time like so we will see no
no but they did it they did it with
sunshine but we got to give
they dave shot some love they gave um it
was just
given a few more in the clip yeah more
on the clip
like yo they got some joints out here
they just need reimagine
shout out to jarv though cause um i'm
gonna have to start using that uh
that chaperone in pve
i made that video about a week ago i was
like let's jump on these slugs they've
got a massive
buff and then i've seen a few videos
come out since but
ultimately they're all hitting the same
notes it's it's no joke
man slug shotguns are are serious
to be honest 30 percent pve buff right
yeah yeah so the num on numbers wise it
it does
more dps than xenophobius situation
but it's it's situational right because
you need to be up close and you need to
have uh
precision hits and stuff so you need to
whereas zeno phase you can just hit fire
it and not have to get the crits right
so
right ease of use xenophage is still
probably the one
but like if you want the actual numbers
then chaperone is actually a better
number but
um i was using by the end of my video i
was using blasphemer and pairing that
with like anarchy and then stacking
those two together
and it's just dirty i'm so happy for
chaperone right now
this is what i'm talking about like chat
listen chap
it was low-key it was a sleeper in pvp
for sure like if you use it you know how
to use it you had skill with it
yeah it was a beast you had the longest
range you know to get it but to see it
it was a gun you'd net
a shotgun you'd never use mpv never
really
and to see it get this pve love again
reimagine this bad boy or buff the class
i love that slugs are getting now the
thing is you know what's crazy i used to
have so many slugs shotguns eve
from like ben what was that one that
used to drop there was one horizon
um yeah norris yeah so that one and i
just have all these crazy rolls like ah
these are trash delete delete delete
delete
and now i'm like damn i have no i want a
legendary i heard the one from
you still got stuff in your vault you
could go back in access
weird it was old it was old i had to i
had to get a body of what i have an
opening shot
outlaw assault mag full bore i mean i
have five of those to pick from right
now
moving target quick draw light mag
hammer forged
you know what it was e i'm so good about
keeping that and for whatever reason i
just
gave up with slugs i was like i don't
think they ever gonna touch it and then
i just just delete i think i got one and
it's just like a pvp role
but i have no pve like you're tall like
these man i want to use these
in um in pve and see how these players
like draw have you been messing
do we do we got any upcoming content on
on top
pv you know legendary slugs that i
should be using sir what should
we talk about um slugwise um
doesn't mean you've got good bone
straight choking or zacks blasphemous
probably
the better one i guess right yeah
yeah that's alter oh yeah the auto sorry
from the chest okay so yeah
they're they're good i mean chaperone is
probably still the one for crucible
though right um
but when you get i mean robots not hard
to activate in pve
so you can you can do some serious
damage with that
for sure um i know i called up i mean i
did a video covering like high impact
pulses
and everyone's been having fun with
those obviously the new pulse rifle for
this season is high impact as well so
uh bungie obviously saw that coming how
do you make this weapon good i know
above the buff the archetype
baby yeah fredricks
yeah so it says yeah cold miles is hot
right now and redrix is as well if
you've still got the quest if
you haven't then you won't be able to
get it yet until bungie fixed that
or you can't put it from your
collections either so um
that's why you don't delete yeah yeah
so yeah so so high impact pulses are
still
a good a good one and obviously trinity
gold got would have got the benefit of
the
small bow buff as well right for
for minus 10 so not only is it crazy now
it does a bit more damage than it did
before so
yeah those are the noticeable ones i
know a few other people
maybe touched on on a few other weapons
teller with feeding friends i got one
give that a shot
give that a shot give um i'm gonna tell
you i'll
give you uh what's it hollow words
diffusion with vorpal
yo boss melters trust me
i'll tell you use and that's not even an
aggressive type
fusion believe it's a uh precision
i've been using i got it to drop with uh
with vorpal it is
you put either a bar spec on that and a
major or a basic whatever you know based
on your playstation
it it belts man it's it's that's the
first time because i feel
like would i even use this overloaded
question let me just see what vorpal on
this fusion is doing
it's special i really like that fusion
so if you guys get that i've been i've
been rocking that a lot
under pressure perhaps that's literally
what i have yeah
we got to say i got it yeah what's your
master work though
hold on uh i got charge time i got
liquid coils oh i'm
charge time and liquid coils for the
bonus damage and then i've either got
hammer forged rifling or
extended barrel so all right oh god shot
yeah
shot that for sure here it
yeah is i don't i don't got the the
charge i got the
the reload yeah world masterwork but
yeah same thing for apple under pressure
i was in um reckoning just tearing up
stuff
tearing up you know yellow balls if you
got a name
like anything that got a name you have a
name i'm gonna delete you
bro don't don't pull up in my gut fire
team and you guys
enemy with a name so you're gonna get it
it's just great especially
if you run out of heavy ammo so i'm
really loving vorpal right now
what other weapons i've been the meta
for pvp i've been liking
i've been liking rhetorics the handling
is still slow i'm not happy that the
fact that um
my man shacks ain't dropping the um no
more redresses no more
with the variations like so i'm stuck
with my default bill which i shouldn't
have deleted the other rhetoric but
that's my own fault
but um he's gonna lash me on that one
again but
yeah man it's been i've been having fun
with the matter i've been really having
fun um
what you call it um where the heart is
we already know
it's just it's it's to do everything man
it's just i'm having so much fun with it
and then
you guys with the sort the sword builds
i've been doing the charge of light
so um yeah we got we got exotic swords
as legendaries
have you guessed energy converter which
one is that
that's a sword the mod from rank it's
the mod from rank 15 of your
pasta
so if you have like supercharged and uh
you can get like up to five stacks of
charge of light and then
by throwing a grenade you can get half
your super back
oh yeah i have it i just haven't used it
because i've been using the one
the other one the one where once you get
charged with light
it gives the sword damage like 30
percent extra
something i've been using that one that
that charge with like
synergy if y'all know what i'm talking
about it's uh yeah yeah yeah is it lucid
blade or something
yeah yeah it's like one of the first
ones yeah yeah yeah i tweeted about that
like the day it was for sale yeah
yeah yeah that's not like that's a must
get mod but yeah the energy converter is
insane
to be honest as well yeah once you get
like stacks it'll go half super
yeah so it's only the first half of your
super though so it won't give you your
second half
and then so it's good for popping so if
you pop your super
grenade and then you've got your half
your grenade and you've got your half
super back and then i was
using it with like bad juju and then
just getting my super back like
string of curses like super again bomb
just
like that putting bubbles down
everywhere just like it was good for all
of sorrow doing waves just putting
bubbles all around the boss
so they thought ahead between combining
that and then crown our skull of
diarrhoea
you can't go first half second half yeah
yeah yeah you got your first half throw
that grenade and now you're full again
that's it obvious rig oh yeah
yes doom thing would have been the other
even need to hit yeah don't even need to
hit an ad either you can just you can
just throw your grenade away just
just touch it off into the trash and you
get halfway super bad
that's pretty good that's actually that
could be really viable
i haven't actually i don't know if i'm
that high on the season stuff yet
i didn't do all that umbrella farming so
i'm playing all normal
i've been there i've been deleting my
hunter and uh doing the first
mission and i saw that yeah i seen you i
was like oh jarvis in his bag with that
new character stuff i love it
i'm glad that they fixed the some of
those
i'm glad they fixed the uh rank to
upgrade because it
it gives you um it puts your twisted
energy directly into your recaster but
what he was doing was only putting half
the energy in
and then the other half was just being
lost so it was taking you twice the time
to upgrade your
recaster if you chose that module but
yeah she should in theory be able to get
two upgrades
every time you do it so oh okay yeah
shout out to cloud plays
um he said any wither horde builds y'all
but yeah i got a fun one
where one of my charger lights with uh
multiple grenade launcher kills
just gives me charge with light and then
i got the
the one that stacks my maximum charger
light to like five
yep yo you know which one is very
underrated and nobody's talking about
once you're charged i think it's like um
it's something like some type of divine
protection so basically what happens is
you get like a shield when you get low
health
yeah but it is if your shield is broken
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're using a protective light
protective light
bro that is my nightfall high level
saver
that has saved me more than you think on
high level content
so what i'll do is i'll just i'll keep
it so basically it's like an insurance
card
you keep your stacks on and then it's
something happening i think i was
playing with some randos one time
and um you know they nobody had
unstoppable mods on on the damn ogres in
the the sabbath doom song seven two
strike
so i'm the only one with like one i must
have used uh my grenade or whatever
and um yeah they get like bum rushed by
this thing and then i'm like oh no it's
just me last guardian left
and then i got hit but then it kicked in
and you see the timer go like whatever
the
protection thing and i'm like oh yeah i
got that i'm good you know and then kind
of save the damn moment
it's really good for high level content
especially if you make mistakes like me
you definitely it's like a nice little
insurance card i've been loving that so
yeah i've been using that
with the horde uh cloudplays i've been
using that with the um the one that
stacks
based on grenade launcher kills because
it's so easy you just throw a puddle on
the ground watch straws run into it
you get like two or three stacks off the
rim you're good to go you're good to go
the stacks on stacks where every one you
get two you'll be stacked all the time
yep that's what i got that one too and
you got that regular mod that you can
put on that just gives you
super energy for getting grenade kills
your class item
the possibilities are endless man you
can keep going into like build territory
baby yeah we are getting in the bills
man i'm like i can't believe
like uh quick thing uh
y'all want you guys to rank the stasis
uh subclasses at least from the picture
we've seen
the ice pickaxes the
i don't know what you'd call the lord of
the rings staff of ice
and then ice fists hulk hands whatever
it looks like ice fish
yeah i hate the conversation this
morning we're houndish about the ice
fist so
i'm gonna wait where are you
trailer man you got to break that stuff
down yeah i'm breaking it down y'all
professionals my bad i forgot
i'm dealing with two professionals here
how could i forget apologies jarvani
boxes
[Laughter]
yeah there's a there's a point where
it's like the three it's the three shot
it's like the all three classes and the
old that's the only time you ever get to
see the titan because you see like
the hunter throw his like axe and
shatter the ground you see the warlock
like holding onto this like
ice staff or white staff or whatever
it's doing and then all you see is this
little tease in the corner of the titan
and he looks like he has giant
icy blocks on his hand that's the best
way i can describe it i don't know if
he's just gonna go around and punch the
hell out of people or what
i'm so confused interesting i gotta look
at that so what do you think
john what do you think is gonna be the
most fun or coolest
when i saw when i saw the titan the the
thing that i thought about the most is a
lot of our super czar
um roaming so i i would like them to
and all the titan supers other than the
bubble tend to be roaming but i i
thought if they go back to like uh
the old fist of havoc so if you slam the
floor
a sheet of ice goes out in front of you
and just freezes everything
solid and you can smash them and see
them just all break
just in front of you being insane
imagine doing that in control just
freezing a point
oh and then just like taking them that's
too much for you titans let's stop it
this is oh
this is way too much no no no stop it
you guys are doing too much you haven't
gonna have like ice pickaxes that are
gonna like
probably shatter and like hit a cone of
frozenness in front of it or something
like
trust me we're not getting boomerangs
they probably just come back and
just keep throwing them yeah
you guys are evil where's my warlocks
getting to combat this like
yeah hey give me some cool magic stuff
man cause we get if they're doing all
this for you guys
whoa that's scary there is a moment
where
it looks like ads are frozen in time
like it looks like either there's some
sort of ability that seems to freeze
them or slow down time so
who knows what looks like the fire's
hanging off there yeah what are
these players down yeah what game
actually did it i'm trying to remember
like what if you throw like a time
grenade
and do what you have to tell me because
i feel like and it actually explodes the
projectiles it doesn't break
okay that might be one yeah and the
remaining break was a lot of time
based yeah like everything is down so
like say you throw it on a night and his
like big giant thing is just like
it just travels really slow and you
could just like move out of the way and
go in and slide away like
that'd be awesome with the sword or
something that'd be kind of fine it'll
be kind of funny
i'm looking forward to stacy's man the
possibilities of what what they're going
to introduce
it's something about september man i
just love it just literally feels like a
game refresh and there's so many new
systems they always add
it's always the most exciting time just
do something man
i'm i i cannot wait to see what they do
with that man but yo i confront
i've been having a ton of fun with
arrivals right now i really have i've
been the builds
the progression so far already has
surpassed season of the worthy i'm
putting it out right now
we didn't even with two weeks it's
better it's better i don't care this
is the russian scene can literally do
nothing and it's already better
it seems a little worthy i am all on the
season of around the train right now
i can see i went to titan for the first
time
yesterday and i was like what where did
this pyramid come from like this
this thing is like veering down there's
i haven't
there's one on titan this week because
i've gone
no the screenshot sorry oh yeah
yeah screenshot of titan which is
probably going to be next week right but
like that's my guess yeah
so which i think is going to move over
there no i think more
or less okay okay yeah arrivals
um
i guess two weeks because they seem to
do everything in these seasons in about
two weeks so it feels like
this one this one and then we're gonna
go titan and then you'll probably have
like a couple going on
and then mars and then mercury you'll
have four ships planted
i don't know what's gonna be like the
look the calm before the storm
and then somewhere and i don't know it
could have been one of your videos
one of who knows the word evacuation
seems to have been a thing i've heard
oh yeah that might be one of mine yeah
yeah so it's like talk to me i watch too
many
so i try and be as on top of it travel
travelers chosen
is there's an evacuation piece for
pretty much
all the destinations that are being
voted yep and that's part of the
traveler's chosen exotic quest as well
yeah
so it looks like that quest is going to
be over multiple weeks there's like 22
steps to it
it's massive i saw it's crazy big yeah
but yeah the fact that we have
evacuation be like all right sloane get
out of here oh
what does vance get off of this planet
anna pack it up
and then you gotta say you gotta save my
homie though just like actually
grab your ass grab your arm let's go
yeah get grumpy ash out of there
i wonder if they're gonna be like
gone like i wonder if they're gonna do
anything with the npc's i hadn't
actually thought about that
i wonder if they were just gonna that
they were gonna be killed
that's what i thought i saw the whole
thing was getting evaporated based on
what was happening but yeah we'll see
we'll see i mean
there's just interesting stuff going on
with vanna but i don't want to talk
spoilers too much
damn i kind of want to know damn it
we'll talk we'll talk after
we'll talk after that
but no yeah i mean i would say season
arrivals kicked off well we have the
exotic
um ruminus i can't even remember the
whole name
effigy i think actually yes yes um
and this isn't spoiler by the way this
is on twitter for one the model looks
amazing
and two it makes black like when you
kill them it makes a little black hole
and that black hole collapses onto a
little
like relic that you pick up and you see
that oh dude run with the relic
slam down and vaporize an ogre
so you're actually going to create some
another like
damaged thing so kill one thing pick it
up
i don't know if you'll be able to throw
it or you'll have to dunk it but either
way
it seems powerful because he just like
takes an ogre clean gun
so i don't know when that's going to
come we have no dates on anything we
literally like
we get week one interference quest we
know we have solstice we know we have
moments of triumph that's it that's like
all we know this season and outside of
that
they're just i'm just gonna log in on
tuesday and be like there's a new exotic
quest right
that's all it is try and do all the
steps as quickly as possible
so if you guys are okay with spoilers go
check out all of jar's videos he's going
to have all the data mind stuff up there
for you
zero shame in the data mining there
i don't have a lot of the data mine
stuff other than the uh traveler's
chosen quest i guess there's a lot of
data mine stuff in there
yeah oh i'm just giving you a hard time
but
hey if people want to prep to at least
be like what do i do he'll let you know
we know yeah 22 steps in under 10
minutes you're welcome
let's go let's go see he's efficient
if you can only watch this while you're
cooking dinner throw an ear pudding
earbud in good to go knock that stuff
out
be prepared that is jarv's motto he's
the boy scouts right here
mm-hmm people get ready get ready
well we are actually at two hours yep
i was gonna say is there anything else
you guys want to talk it's a weird week
like i know we're just getting into
arrivals there's a lot to talk about
there's still so much speculation over
the future but also like
there's not anything specific that
dropped per se this week
right we still don't want to show two
hours though always
yeah we definitely hit it i want to give
a shout out to the homie man shout out
to scarole
did you see the homie get dimension with
the raid tunes bro he killed it
oh that was good and he had some good
rankings i don't know about that spy
stars number one
but music wise he had the classics
though he had
he had the axis joint he had you know i
go a lot even though you don't i mean i
love king's fault but that's not my
moment king falls great
i go front door he killed that oryx
steam he
killed that ory like that was dead on so
shout out to him on that
and then he had my favorite is number
two which was the uh queen's walk theme
when you leave him leaving out yeah he
he destroyed it man
yeah forte yeah he killed that [ __ ] i'm
scared we've had him on last word a
bunch of times man it was cool to see
him get that recognition
on the uh the the mentioned honorable
mention by bungie on the 12 that was
dope
and he geared up you see the shirt you
see my man how clean my man
had a scary shirt and everything he had
to do it he had to go he went big he was
awesome he went big man he went big
that's what's up man
you know did shout out to daniel he said
did i mention yeah i will mention that
down
on my outro i will definitely mention
that then i got you
hmm gotcha yeah um but yeah guys the gcx
stream is still going on
so go check out see if you want to
support somebody go for some of the
crazy giveaways they did in sunday
uh i don't even know where they're at
for a total right now actually i'm going
to check real quick out of sheer
curiosity because yesterday was
stupidly large number by the time bungie
just got done
um what they do
man like last year they got to i think
combined everything was like 3 8
right for everything right and that was
like when we were wrapping up gcx and i
think like the
convention and this time we're sitting
at
four i'm waiting for it to load
4.7 million so far and it's
friday morning you still have saturday
you still have sunday you still have
lupo
like yep that's crazy so
new record again coming for gcs it's
already there it's only getting bigger
so
that's pretty awesome well yeah i don't
have anything else to you guys some
it's it's weird like i know i've been
playing a lot oh by the way last of us
too
it came out so if you guys are looking
to
enjoy some of that by uh through me i'll
be streaming that thing as we go
i got through the first major story beat
last night and shut it down so we'll be
picking that one up later today as well
that's what's up man y'all be hitting
that this weekend probably later in the
week just got lost
you're playing through one first though
yeah
i'm close you know about 70 and just
like it fresh
before i jump into that part two but
yeah i'll be i'll be hitting it jarv
will you mention do you
or do you like live in the destiny world
i know lately you have been obviously
but do you like branch out for other
stuff we didn't actually go like
other game types you like i was actually
just kind of curious like other stuff
you play
um time is limited obviously with uh
doing this uh full time now but uh we
spoke before about some other sort of
play test stuff that i've got coming up
next week
with a mid-winded entertainment game uh
scavengers so i'd like to
say other like indie games and stuff
like that um
i would love to be able to sit down and
invest times into
fantastic story different games like
last of us and stuff like that but
i i just don't have the time
unfortunately so anything that's
more session based that i can sort of
hop in and hop out you know 20 minutes
half hour 40 minutes here and there is
probably
more suited to where i am right now
unfortunately
yep now we understand you got that
content you're producing getting that
out there
yeah man for me i'll definitely hit that
bad boy up too
at some point but um yeah it's been it's
been on my little destiny grind man just
been loving it
you know as much as the time time i do
get to play you know i've been
really enjoying the grind so far
well um jarv if you want to we can
actually wrap this thing up if you want
to tell them all the places they can
find you
any got any videos on your uh calendar
wall
if you got some cool stuff that they can
look forward to a little sneak peek
action
what do you what do you got coming up
sir and where can they find you find
your content best place to
see what's going on uh you can find me
pretty much
venus anywhere twitter youtube pretty
much any platform you'll find me
if you just search jarv destiny you'll
find me on youtube relatively easily
um got zero in a few hours so that'd be
my my content for today i'm still
mapping out
saturday and sunday uh for this week so
no spoilers
for those just you guys but yeah
um yeah i'm still mapping out the uh
coming weeks it's really hard with the
road maps being
relatively light trying to map stuff out
like we used to be able to
um but that's the it's also exciting as
well because you have to react quick
so it's all about reacting tuesday is an
open day because you never know what's
coming so
i like to prepare something for tuesday
so or at least get 70
of it done for tuesday so if nothing
really happens and
then i can spend an hour or two
finishing to provide something
still a good time um rather than putting
all my eggs in one basket get to six
o'clock which is uk time reset and be
like
oh there's nothing oh damn
uh so yeah i don't want to leave myself
short i guess this man is this man is a
pro out here he's a pro
oh yeah oh yeah look at the profession
in the world fashionable man yeah
got a white board up there with just
ideas flowing to it
amazing stuff no man i wish it was true
it's always hard trying to be like am i
going to copy somebody else's do it like
you got to do your own stuff but no you
have been it's awesome to see your eyes
and it's been well justified because
you've been putting out some great stuff
so
yeah happy very happy to have you on
here pleasure to have you
and dude just keep working hard you are
absolutely crushing it right now so just
ride that momentum train as long as
it'll go enjoy
man i appreciate that dude thanks for
having me man it's been a blast we've
had a
better laugh having laughing a good time
yeah absolutely man salute cognito sir
what do you got coming i know sunday is
always fun for you guys uh but what do
you got coming up
yeah but sunday lord's day you already
know um 1 p.m eastern
youtube and all the platforms do twitch
as well you can follow me through this
profile here twitch make sure all that
good stuff yeah we're going to have a
dan
rodriguez from season gaming you know a
bunch of industry
vets lots talk about what's going on in
the gaming world a lot of hot topics
going on right now we obviously we got
that last of us we got the cyberpunk
delay
we've got all type of things going on so
please tune in
for that i'm happy about that delay i
really am
i'll be honest i'm happy about that i'm
happy about it too okay
i'm so happy about that next time
september was gonna be awful so no
that's so much better
september would have been awful we know
what was coming for us for destiny you
know i'm saying that kind of stuff
so um yeah man it was definitely you
know
something i'm looking forward to and um
you also want to put in the chat for you
guys we are actually doing a giveaway
so it's a gleam giveaway right now we're
doing that strangers
edition now here's the catch normally we
do multi-platform giveaways but in this
case because we're giving away
that statue that is a gamestop exclusive
i believe that stranger joint
you know we had to pick one so we picked
xbox this one
because um because you had that because
you had to
because i had to i was like what about a
pig
i was like we got playstation just to
see if what the podcast reaction would
be that's what we did stop it
we always we just gave away last one but
good point
valid pointy but oh yeah we're doing
that joining xbox and obviously they got
announced for smart delivery so xbox
guys
please you know what i'm saying check
that out what's going on um
really cool thing so go check that out
or obviously on the
lordsgaming.net man appreciate the
support it's it's been moving it's been
growing we're loving what we're saying
right there so
check out those articles at lords of
gaming.net tremendous writers
and of course the king uh king of
statues great statue of you guys are
into
comic book statues things like that
x-men he's got a great
captain america winter soldier one of my
favorite mcu movies
he's got that one up there right there
and of course you know me laura cogdino
on twitter first of all salute off man
salute y'all for coming through man
tremendous tremendous growth love the
channel
love what i'm seeing keep doing what
you're doing brother and love talking
destiny with you you are extremely
knowledgeable sir
and this is always so hopeful we have
you back soon but that's all i got man
yeah mine's easy ibantus everywhere ebo
and tis twitch twitter youtube
uh as i said i will be playing last word
i will be playing the last of us part
two apparently my mind is at least not
that good
messing up with that right moment but
yeah zur of course
yeah uh i don't know who it was i think
it was civitec once i don't know if you
ever saw that tweet
um jarv and he said i know it's friday
because this is what my youtube feed
looks like and i think it was you
me and one other person it was zerzer on
his youtube feed and it was like right
around noon it was just like
he's like yep i know what time it is on
friday no
we will be doing our zur videos here in
about 90 minutes
of course um he's got random rolls at
least so thank god there's a little more
life into that one
which is good because you know they can
they were all over 60 last week
so stay tuned to those they're
definitely a good thing you can use your
exotic ciphers too right so if you hit
level 55 on the season pass you can get
a second faded engram for the week if
you uh
already have all the exotics from
previous seasons so
don't waste it use it if you need it
yeah
absolutely absolutely shout out to
senator coming in late when we end in
salute to senator
it's like hi he's like hey i made it
yeah oh my god salute to the clan
iop well um jarv we do try and wrap this
thing up we're always a little
ridiculous when we do but i'm going to
kind of do all the outro and then i'm
going to give this big pause i'm going
to say it it has been
the way i was trying to say the last
word together joy is a post i can always
fix this later but
let's wrap this thing up and then don't
turn off your recording we'll fix this
up sinister at 1064.
yeah he's beasted right i know he's
crazy so well thank you guys everybody
this has been awesome
jarvinus uh venus sorry i'm probably
gonna say that wrong a couple times
uh awesome to have you man glad to get
you on here
um a ton of fun go get iron lords
podcast
let that fill your ears on sunday come
hang out with me and last of us part two
lots of good things going on but episode
108 we got to wrap this thing up
uh june 19th it's a good day and it's
the start of the weekend so enjoy your
weekend and thank you guys for all
coming in
and for this episode it has been
the last word